welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Tim Ferris Tim Ferriss is an
author a podcaster an investor and is
known for having a near Supernatural
ability to predict the future which has
allowed him to obtain success in a huge
number of different Endeavors for
instance he is a five-time number one
New York Times best-selling author
but perhaps equally or more important to
that he's also exceptionally good at
teaching people how to write the entire
process of writing and marketing a book
his books the four-hour chef and the
four-hour body and the four hour work
week not only explain his own
exploration of how to optimize and
prioritize his time and learn particular
skills but he teaches you those skills
as well this is really what sets him
apart he is an exceptional learner and
an exceptional teacher and today you
learn why that is and in a
characteristic Tim Ferriss way he
explains the process in a way that you
can apply it he lists out for instance
the specific questions that you should
ask When approaching any Endeavor in
order to get the information that you
want and to make the process of learning
and getting better at something and
achieving great success in something
that much more likely that ability that
Tim has to identify the specific
questions that one needs to ask and
answer and the specific action steps to
take in order to achieve success is
really what I believe sets Tim apart
from everyone else on the Internet or on
the bookshelf that's giving advice as to
how to become good at something
Tim Ferriss is also dedicated to various
philanthropic efforts the most recent of
which is the donation of several
millions of his own dollars to research
on psychedelics for the treatment of
otherwise intractable psychiatric
challenges such as major depression
suicidal depression eating disorders and
addiction and he's also brought together
other philanthropists which has really
galvanized the whole field of
psychedelic research for the treatment
of mental health transforming it from
what was recently kind of a fringe area
of science to a Mainstay that's actually
funded not only by philanthropy but by
the National Institutes of Health so
he's really transformed this entire
scientific field into one that now is
transforming the laws around
psychedelics and is providing mental
health treatment for people that would
otherwise suffer today's discussion was
a particularly meaningful one because
not only is Tim a Pioneer in the world
of podcasting but it also marked the
nine-year anniversary of his podcast the
Tim Ferriss show now as I mentioned
earlier Tim is known for being able to
see around corners or predict the future
he really does seem to be about five if
not 10 years ahead of everybody else in
thinking about tools for optimization in
particular domains of life and so we
were very fortunate that during today's
discussion he shares with us his current
creative Endeavors and how he's thinking
about and approaching those and he also
breaks down for us the process of how to
think about and prioritize one scheduled
not just on the order of the day not
just on the order of the week but really
thinking about one's life as a journey
and how to organize and go about that
Journey so today's discussion will
provide with you tremendous insight into
who Tim Ferriss is and how that
incredible mind of his Works in order to
do all the amazing things that he's done
and of course he teaches you how to do
it he will tell you the exact questions
that you should ask and
that you should answer and how to step
back and think about those questions and
then prioritize so that you can decide
how to best invest your time I'm sure
many of you are familiar with the Tim
Ferriss show however if you're not
already subscribing to the Tim Ferriss
show I highly recommend you do I still
go back and listen to early episodes of
the Tim Ferriss show and I'm a weekly
listener to the new episodes we provide
a link to the Tim Ferriss show in the
show note captions also in the show note
captions you'll find links to Tim's many
New York Times best-selling books and a
link to his excellent weekly blog before
we begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Maui Nui venison Maui Nui venison is the
most nutrient dense and delicious red
meat available I've talked before on
this podcast about the key importance of
striving to get one gram of protein per
pound of body weight now when one
strives to do that it's also important
to maximize the quality protein to
calorie ratio in other words you don't
want to consume a lot of extra calories
in order to get your quality protein
Maui Nui venison in having an extremely
high quality protein and nutrient to
calorie ratio allows you to do that very
easily and in addition to that Maui Nui
venison is delicious I particularly like
their bone broth which has an unmatched
25 grams of protein per 100 calories I
also love their ground venison and their
venison steaks all of them are
absolutely delicious if you'd like to
try Maui Nui venison go to
mauinuyvenison.com huberman and get 20
off your first order again that's Maui
News venison.com huberman to get 20 off
today's episode is also brought To Us by
element element is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need that is the
electrolytes sodium magnesium and
potassium but nothing you don't which
means no sugar it's critical that we get
electrolytes because every cell of our
body but in particular our nurse cells
our neurons rely on electrolytes in
order to function properly with element
it's very easy to ingest the correct
ratios of electrolytes that come in
these little packets they're really
delicious you mix them up with anywhere
from 8 to 16 to 32 ounces of fluid I
like mine pretty concentrated so I'll
drink a 16 ounce glass of water with
element in it when I first wake up I'll
also consume another one of those maybe
32 ounces with one packet when I
exercise and maybe another one if I
happen to sweat a lot during exercise or
if I was in the sauna and sweating lot
if it's a very hot day Etc if you'd like
to try element go to drink element
that's lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you see how different foods and
activities impact your blood glucose
levels or blood sugar levels as they're
sometimes referred to
with levels you can see how the specific
foods you eat when you eat and exercise
as well as any other activities impact
your blood glucose and how those affect
things like your energy level or your
quality of sleep or your level of
clarity and focus for mental work or
your physical output for physical
Endeavors I first started using levels
about a year ago as a way to understand
how different foods and activities
impact my blood glucose levels and it's
really impacted my entire schedule in
fact I've shuffled a number of things
around such that now I have more stable
energy throughout the day yes I
eliminated one or two Foods fortunately
they weren't my favorite foods I've also
added some new foods to my nutrition
program that have allowed my blood sugar
levels to remain much more steady
throughout the day and to achieve better
sleep at night levels even provides a
simple score after any meal you eat so
you can see how different foods affect
you and develop a personalized nutrition
program that's exactly right for you and
that's really what levels is about it's
really about tailoring things to your
specific needs so if you're interested
in learning more about levels and trying
a CGM yourself go to levels.link
huberman right now they're offering an
additional two free months of membership
again that's levels.link huberman and
now for my discussion with Tim Ferris
Tim Ferriss
I am nothing short of thrilled to have
you here
I've been reading your books reading
your blogs listening to your podcasts
for a very long time and in preparing
for today
I was thinking you know who does Tim
remind me of because I knew you reminded
me of somebody but I didn't know who and
then I realized it you remind me of the
neurobiologist ramoni kahal you don't
look anything like him
he doesn't look anything like you uh he
was a brilliant scientist he won the
Nobel Prize in 1906 for essentially
describing the structure of the nervous
system it was the first along with
another guy to Define synapses like this
fundamental connection the nervous
system but the reason that you remind me
of kahal
is that it's a well-known or not so
secret secret in Neuroscience that if
you want to pick a really excellent
project to work on you simply go and
look at what kahal
talked about or hypothesized
and then you work on that yeah he had
this almost
um
Supernatural ability to look at fixed
stained tissue of the nervous system
much of it is incredibly beautiful by
the way
and
think about how it worked when it was
alive and he's considered the greatest
neurobiologist of all time without
question
and
it's really this feature of being able
to like see around corners or into the
future that establishes that link for me
it's it's absolute truth that if you
look back to what you were doing 10
years ago 15 years ago the kinds of
things you were doing the kinds of
questions you were asking
that translates to much of what people
like myself and people in the fitness
space Tech space investor space
mindfulness space psychedelic space all
these different arenas
what they're doing now so um it's not
hyperbole to say that you are the ramoni
kahal of all those different spaces and
podcasting of course is one of those so
I owe you a great debt of gratitude and
many others do as well so my first
question for you is
what was your mindset around the time
that you wrote for our body
four hour work week but in particular
four hour body because the protocols in
that book are so very useful they were
at the time it was published they still
are now and so many of the things like
ice baths the discussion around Brown
fat thermogenesis
um resistance training in its uh you
know kind of basic form of just
providing enough Progressive overload to
get an adaptation not excessively long
workouts weight loss slow carb diet
um and on and on and on what were you
thinking at that time like if you can
think back to then like what were you
foraging for were you thinking about
when you woke up in the morning thinking
oh I'm gonna go find all this stuff that
at the time was really esoteric because
it is all played out very well
um what I'm basically saying is if you
want to know what's going to be
happening hot and useful in five years
ten years and onwards just look at what
Tim's doing at any moment so there it is
well thank you for the very generous
comparison and intro I'm thrilled to be
here so thanks for having me and
the for our body represented an
opportunity for me to do a few things
the first was to diversify my identity
from outside of the realm of the say
business category so it was a deliberate
move since the success of the first book
book The permission
to do something else that Publishers
would still want to gamble on
I wanted to see if I could maybe like
Michael Lewis take my audience with me
to other topics so that was a lateral
move that was very deliberate from a a
career optionality standpoint and then I
was doing I think what I've done for a
very long time and what I enjoy doing
which is looking at the most
prevalent beliefs and maybe dogmatic
assumptions in a given field
could be anything if anyone says always
never should I pay attention and take
note of that they may very well be right
but if anything is said in absolutes I
like to stress test and in the case of
say physical performance or physical
manipulation
tracking
2008 2009 was a very interesting time
because a number of different
Technologies were coming online meaning
being adopted by small groups he had the
very early stages of say accelerometers
as wearables you had a number of
different Innovations and means of
tracking that had never been available
before you had for instance
and this took a bit of ferreting on my
side it wasn't immediately on the
roadmap for our body but continuous
glucose monitors
at the time that was I want to say
exclusively limited to type 1 diabetics
or maybe type 2 diabetics but largely
type 1 diabetics and what captured my
interest and I can't recall how I came
across it but it was probably through
the very earliest iterations of what
later became the Quantified Self
movement
and I remember attending the very first
gathering at Kevin Kelly's house in
Pacifica California this is this was
around 2009
12 people 13 people to discuss
quantifying Health but
the the example of a professional race
car driver I can't remember the the form
factor whether it was F1 or Nascar or
other who was using this continual
glucose monitor for
paying attention to glucose levels while
driving
and I thought to myself
would that not be useful for healthy
normals would that not have other
applications if this if this is being
used by high performer in this type of
context might it have other types of
applications which then led me to use
the very early versions of Dexcom which
were really painful to implant no longer
the case of course that's changed a lot
and
I wanted to see how I might be able to
find a handful of different categories
of things there's the new like the
genuinely new like CGM at that point was
genuinely new the very old
that might have some room for scientific
investigation and I would say when I say
scientific I don't necessarily mean
randomized controlled trials at a
university I do think as an N of one
if you think about study design and you
can even blind you could even Placebo
control and I knew people in the small
subculture of Quantified Self who did
this you can I think approach things in
a methodical way where you can make a
lot of progress in trying to determine
causality or lack thereof looking at
very old things looking at orphaned
things so for instance
there are many examples in the world of
doping where you have say Balco back in
the day where famously Barry Bonds and
others purportedly use things like the
cream and the clear and these were based
on anabolics that were sourced from
Soviet literature or older literature
from the 50s and 60s that might not be
on the radar of say the anti-doping
groups that would administer the testing
so all of these different buckets were
of interest to me and I begin where I
usually do which is interviewing folks
so I would interview one or two people
in a given field and I might ask them
any number of questions so one is what
are the Nerds doing on the weekends or
at night this is also really good for
investing it's like all right what are
the really technical nerds doing
at night or on the weekends after
they've put in a really long work day or
work week let's take a really close look
at that another one is and I'll create a
flow for this but what are rich people
doing now
that everyone or
tens or hundreds of millions of people
might be doing
10 years from now
and an example of that would be let's
just say full-time assistant virtual
assistant AI
right so we've seen the needs and wants
being addressed by different technology
but it's an iteration of the same thing
on some level
in the case of say using chat GPT tied
into zapier for various functions
and then where are people cobbling
together awkward Solutions
so where are people piecing together
awkward Solutions
and is there room for some type of
innovation there these are a few of the
questions that I would not only ask
myself but ask experts in different
areas so if I end up spending time say
this was a few years prior to
writing the for our body I spent time at
NASA Ames and was interacting with a
number of scientists some people who
were working on all sorts of biological
tests and looking at genomics
and had a very Frank discussion about
where they thought if they had to push
right so I'll ask questions like
push a little bit into the realm of
Science Fiction and speculation because
I'm sure you can't support
any type of projection like that with
the literature with scientific
literature but what do you think some of
the risks are of say publishing your
genome because at the time a number of
high profile folks had just made their
full genomes available and they're like
well I think in the near future it'd be
possible to reconstruct someone's face
based on their genetic data
and they're like high degree of
confidence like zero to 100 how
confident yeah 80 90 I'm like okay I
should pay attention to that because if
you're making your data available let's
just say and it's anonymized per se you
still might be identifiable it's like
okay that raises some interesting
questions like okay well then how might
you get around that how might you put in
safeguards so that you are the one and
only keeper of your data so to speak
I brought up all sorts of targeted
Weaponry uh by sort of Bio weapons
possibilities that I was interested in
and then I would ask that person who's
clearly like willing to
step outside of the box of whatever he's
working on day to day
who are two of your close friends or two
thinkers you really pay a lot of
attention to are kind of at the bleeding
edge of something and unorthodox and
then I would just continue to have these
conversations over and over again and
the the the the these the stream of
development that I paid a lot of
attention to is something along the
lines of the following so the the
the very Beginnings are usually in some
type of extreme case and I think the
extremes
and this goes for product design as well
but the extremes inform the mean but not
vice versa so you can actually learn a
lot by studying the edge cases so
racehorses for instance uh you'll often
see things start with say raise horses
uh or people with wasting diseases for
instance or any type of chronic
or terminal illness who are willing to
try
some more experimental interventions
then let's just take one step further
bodybuilding see a lot of interesting
behavior in bodybuilding and high-level
athletes then billionaires then rich
people than the rest of us right so
my assumption is and was for the for our
body that
along the lines of William Gibson's
quote you know the future is already
here it's just not evenly distributed so
I'm never predicting the future I'm just
finding the seeds that are germinating
that I think are going to bloom and end
up spreading really really widely so
that's that's that's generally where I
start and I assume the practitioners are
going to be ahead of the papers
so studying say the coaches
whose jobs are on the line who are
getting paid based on Athlete
Performance
and assuming that a lot of that will
eventually
if it holds up make its way into say the
peer-reviewed exercise science papers
but it's going to have a lag time of
three to five years at least at least at
least takes a long time yeah science is
often very slow to catch up
um
you mentioned many things that have
questions about
um you mentioned paying attention to the
new the very old or the orphaned
um
so interesting and I just thought I'd
tell you that when you sit down with a
graduate student or a postdoc and
they're trying to come up with a project
rarely do you say you know like what do
you want to work on and they fire back
like a really interesting
question sometimes they do but that's
the rare person more often than not
you'll send them to the literature and
they'll come back with like okay there's
this new technique that we can use to
answer a set of questions better than
ever before where there's a very old
Theory I want to revisit or there's this
theory that no one pays attention to in
fact we had one guest on here Odette
rashavi who is studying it essentially
inheritance of traits transgenerational
inheritance of traits that's a little
bit although different from lamarkian uh
Evolution but it's a lot like that
um in some ways and you know these
orphan theories that everyone assumed
were wrong and that there is a basis for
them so I think there's Real Genius in
that analysis
um it also struck me as you were listing
off some of your process Circa the the
writing of the four-hour body that
I and many other people are probably
curious about what the operations around
all that looked like so are you or were
you at the time like waking up in the
morning going okay I'm gonna take a walk
and think about the new the old and the
orphaned or
um
well I'm gonna take a walk or sit in and
share anything about like what are the
Nerds doing right now what are rich
people doing right now and cobbling
together awkward Solutions was was that
exploration a structured practice for
you or is this just something that
um was the consequence of being Tim
Ferriss waking up in the morning and
just like leaning into that because I've
experienced both right you know but I
think a lot of us are uh Curious I mean
that there's a lot of Mystique around
you
um whether you like us to dispel it
whether whether you like it or not
um it it it's there and um and we're not
trying to to pry but pry away is the is
the establishment of structure for you
something that's the consequence of
structure in the first place it's like
okay now it's time to think or do you
just allow things to geyser up to the
surface
I do both and I would say that in the
case of the four-hour body it's it's a
bit of an anomaly
compared to my later books because I had
recorded effectively every work ad I'd
done since age 16 as a competitive
athlete I just I had a lot of records
and I kept copious notes on supplement
use and everything imaginable so I have
what you might call hypergraphia I just
capture it
almost everything in writing and that
was very useful because at various
points in time let's just say I looked
at a photograph of myself from making
this up but
2004 and I think I would like to look
and feel like that again okay let me
revisit my workout logs let me just
replicate the proceeding three to six
months of workouts and look at my intake
and my diet at the time and lo and
behold more or less I could replicate
the same type of look and feel and
performance so I had a lot already
logged that I thought was worth
examining and putting under scrutiny
trying to replicate with other people I
do think replication is really important
and then when it came time to commit to
writing the book I thought about what
types of
many books would be of great interest to
me personally and that book like many of
my other books was written in such a
fashion that it could be a Choose Your
Own Adventure book did not need to be
read in fact in many ways it shouldn't
be read linearly from page one to the
end you get to pick and choose which
chapters are of Interest based on breath
hold vertical jump endurance hypertrophy
cold exposure for fat loss whatever it
might be
and then I began talking to people and
at the at the very outer bounds of
self-experimentation at least in the Bay
Area it's a pretty small community so
you're one or two lily pads from just
about everyone and it's not accidental
that I put myself in that environment in
San Francisco specifically
and more generally in the Bay Area
Silicon Valley because there's just a
high surface area for luck to stick to
because you have so many serendipitous
encounters you have so many people
focusing on different disciplines that I
think was the
fertilizer
and the fertile ground for everything
else was actually the choosing the wear
of writing physically being located in
San Francisco and then when I'm
structuring things
maybe I'll get into some of the
nitty-gritty but I was using at the time
and I still like to use a program called
scrivener which is actually designed
predominantly for screenwriting it's
used for many things now novels and so
on it's expanded it's reached quite a
bit but it allows you to gather research
and all of your documents and drafts so
that you can move them around in very
novel ways so you can view say a split
pane of your research and what you're
working on simultaneously without having
to toggle between a lot of different
windows and I was very promiscuous in my
gathering of data so I would gather from
say the web using a Web Clipper from
Evernote which I was involved with as a
company and
basically without bias capture as much
as possible put three asterisks next to
anything that I thought I really might
want to revisit after I had read
something a second time which I would
always do then I could control F to find
just three asterisks because they don't
occur much in normal writing just like
people authors writers will you use TK
meaning find such and such a date data
needs to be inserted later but I don't
interrupt the flow of writing let me
putting TK because it doesn't really
appear in natural English much uh in
terms of structured thinking the way I
approached it was
during that period of time in my life it
was interviews tracking people down
conversations emails reading so
ingestion let's just say for the workday
then a break for training and and
actually using myself as the human
guinea pig for various things that had
surfaced that might be on the docket
where were you training at that time San
Francisco is not famous for amazing gyms
it's not famous for amazing gems at the
time I was training mostly at a Climbing
Gym called Mission Cliffs they didn't
have much but they had barbells and they
had and they had kettlebells yep I also
had in the in the walkway leading from
the front door of the apartment I was
renting is more of a house the front
door all the way to the first set of
stairs there were 30 kettlebells of
various types and I was training for
certification because I wanted to put
myself on some type of deadline with
accountability for that type of training
to get a better understanding of it so
train for a few hours I also had
developed a friendship with Kelly
Starrett so San Francisco CrossFit who I
have tremendous amount of respect for
likewise on multiple levels terrific and
his new book
yeah not to move this great book he's so
good yeah he he really not only talks
the talk but walks the walk and
exemplifies many of the capabilities
that he teaches which I take seriously I
like practitioners not just the people
with pretty theories although the
theories are important I prefer to see
someone who can actually put them into
practice so Kelly served that function
uh certainly and we're still very close
friends
and then
after that all right shake off the
cobwebs get the body moving get the
brain moving also eat and then I would
actually focus on synthesis so I would
write generally from let's call it
9 00 PM or 10 p.m through to 4 or 5 a.m
and I would ride the wave if I happen to
be in the zone if I weren't in the zone
I wouldn't force it and I would try to
get more sleep but I have always
performed best with my writing in those
witching hours of let's call it 10 P.M
to 4 AM and my experience is that
The Writer's I've interviewed the writer
friends I've become close with
if you look at when they made themselves
not necessarily what they do now right
but what they did that eventually got
them to escape velocity
they're almost always doing most of
their writing very late at night or very
early in the morning when the rest of
the world or their social group is
inactive wow yeah and I say wow because
of course all of this was prior to the
publication of Matt Walker's seminal
book right why we sleep which I really
see is the book that shifted
a lot of people fortunately from the
I'll sleep when I'm dead mindset uh too
I'll you know to really paying attention
to it and um you know I don't think Matt
gets enough credit I mean there there's
been a revision of a few points within
that book but the majority of it is just
spot on and Hyper legitimate so good and
um and yet what you're describing is a
schedule that you know starting to write
at 9 00 pm and finishing up around 4am
but you talked about research earlier
that day and training and eating so were
there naps in there I would sleep
from say four to maybe 11 or 12. so I
would be getting up later and I've had
conversations with Matt about this and
there are
night owls and morning Larks and there
are certainly differences in the code
meaning the genetics but that worked
very very well for me for a very long
time it is however a very
challenging social schedule so once you
have a significant other and every
girlfriend I've ever had is a morning
person if you want to spend time
together that schedule just does not
work so I made compromises later for the
social side of things but if if you put
a gun to my head and said you need to
write the best book humanly possible
that is your only priority outside of
some exercise and fuel I would follow
the same schedule I know several very
successful podcasters Lex Friedman in
particular who I think he's trying to
follow a more normal schedule now but
he's pseudo nocturnal at least by my ex
my read and there are a couple other
online content creators Derek from more
plates more dates who's hyper productive
in his domain and is mostly nocturnal
and then as you're describing your
writing routine and your overall routine
I was thinking that you know the the
great skateboarder everyone knows Tony
Hawk who is obviously a great
skateboarder no doubt about that but
Rodney Mullen who invented the ollie on
Street the kickflip the only like Rodney
is basically nocturnal and has been for
a long time and would you know
skateboard up and down the boardwalk in
Santa Monica in the middle of the night
because lack of distraction yes it
really was and he's been doing that
since his teens I don't know what he's
doing these days but I think a lot of
creators just need space and and I
always wonder if that's because when
they at least the ones that are not uh
socially dysfunctional like yourself who
when they are around people there's just
almost hopefully a desire to interact so
you almost have to remove the stimulus
completely yeah it it it removes the
plausible deniability which might not be
the perfect use of that phrase but in
the sense that you it's harder to fool
yourself into thinking you're doing
something important when you're checking
your messages or social media at two in
the morning who are we kidding folks you
should be writing in this case right and
writers will do anything to avoid
writing I remember iron and wrote a book
about writing which is actually
fantastic I can't remember the exact
title it might just be on non-fiction
writing something like that and she
talked about polishing the sneakers or
the shoes before writing like I really
just need to do this one thing which is
to just clean up that shoe because
somebody should really clean it up and
at some point I should clean it up and
therefore why don't I just do there's no
time like the president I'll just do
that and it's all to avoid writing which
is the harder thing and in my
conversations with Matt also I should
say that
as someone who has self-described as a
person who struggles with onset insomnia
Matt made the point and sometimes we
need to relearn things
maybe you should just go to bed later
sure and that might address some of this
onset insomnia and I don't know the
causes for that but I do get a second
win very late could be related to some
cortisol release abnormality or just
different scripting in my system who
knows I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be in the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health and those
probiotics and athletic greens are
optimal and vital for microbiotic health
in addition athletic greens contains a
number of adaptogens vitamins and
minerals that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs are met
and it tastes great if you'd like to try
athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 I'll
mention one other
one other maybe sheuristic that I use
for trying to peek around corners which
is
if I find an example of an outlier
trying to find two or three right
because one is an exception two is
interesting three is worth investigating
that's sort of how I think about it and
I recognize the plural of anecdote does
not equal data however a lot of
interesting discoveries begin as case
studies or case histories and so there
are some things we could talk about that
that I've paid attention to over the
last few years that are not in the for
our body that I think are
quite interesting and raise very very
exciting questions but I'd love to hear
about those yeah and along the lines of
what I call anec data I mean most of
what we know about human memory stems
from one patient hm who had his
hippocampi removed for epilepsy and of
course I've been on Millions probably
close to millions of studies in animals
and humans focusing on the hippocampi
but most of what we know about human
memory is from one guy yeah yeah exactly
so there's
there's there's a lot to be examined not
all of it will get funding for rcts
let's be realistic this is especially
true if you're hoping for any type of
directive data notice I'm not saying
conclusive but if you are a human who's
going to be making decisions about diet
Health exercise if you want any
consensus you're doomed you'll be you're
not going to get any answers before you
die can you say that twice so that the
internet can hear it extra loud and
clear for those of you that are arguing
about nutrition on Twitter like it it
might actually be life wasted yeah I
mean I'm not being judgmental I mean I
think that there's validity in lots of
those Pockets there's stuff that's wrong
in lots of those Pockets yeah
um they're diets that work extremely
well like you know four hour diet it's a
slow carb I always called the four hour
diet but the Slow Carb Diet yeah it
works extremely well anytime I've
followed it I get much leaner and
stronger and all that stuff
that it's purported to do it it works
um but yeah maybe you could just uh
explain what you mean by that because I
think there are some argument slash
friction spaces that are truly an energy
sink yeah I would just say focus on what
works for you and your family or your
team and
if you're arguing on the internet
recognize that you're just doing it
because you like arguing on the internet
you're not going to convince anyone of
anything
and uh
you're just gonna make yourself uh more
frustrated if you plan on changing any
opinions so for me it's Live and Let
Live and
uh the more people who engage in that
type of behavior the more competitive
Advantage do you have if you don't so
for me I'm like okay if you want to
spend this vital
non-renewable resource of yours called
time on that
if I ever compete against you I'm going
to win so great I'll just uh I'll also
not even try to convince you to stop
doing that unless you see the logic in
it which I have which is why I also
don't have at least for two years have
mostly had no social apps installed on
my phone uh and we could talk about that
because I think recognizing that these
things have been engineered to overcome
any type of self-discipline with
billions of dollars
at stake uh should lead you to believe
that you're bringing a knife to a
gunfight so I just don't have the apps
on my phone to begin with
and I find it much more gratifying to
see
disproportionate change
from small inputs so that's what I'm
looking for and I'm also looking for
changes that are easy to make
that can have high adherence that have
very limited downside which is very
different from proving something
for instance in the for our body took a
look at the potential effect of cell
phones or the proximity of cell phones
to say gonadal function and reproductive
health
and the literature that was available at
the time was very limited had some
animal studies mice rats Etc I recognize
humans are not just large mice so they
don't always translate but I looked at I
said okay
looking at this simplistically is a
plausible that there could be similar
effects on humans seems to be the case
also based on conversations with people
who are Specialists but would never go
on record therefore
if your phone is in your pocket just
have it on airplane mode I mean it does
not have a high cost
and and then
pending any revision we can see but
while the jury is still out I'm going to
risk mitigate by taking this step well
and I just want to say uh thank you
there too I read that recommendation I
followed the recommendation of not
keeping the phone on in my front pocket
or back pocket
um again that's anecdata
um
my sperm analysis isn't relevant to this
conversation but worked out but you know
you could say well that's not
necessarily because you had the phone
off but um I did a very long detailed
episode on male and female fertility
there is now a what I view as a really
quality meta-analysis and it's pretty
clear that there are effects of the
smartphone on proximity of the
smartphone when it's turned on uh that
are not good for sperm isn't necessarily
going to render somebody sterile but on
sperm that can be separated out from the
heat effects and so essentially this is
another instance in which you're you're
right and I think more data will come
out and Mia EMF conspiracy theorists uh
no
um do I wear tin foil underwear no
but uh I think it's interesting I think
it's important and thanks to you
um it cued my attention to it in fact I
teach about that in a course on on
neural circuits and biology and health
and disease amazing and I don't expect
to get everything right at all yeah that
would be crazy I'd like to think I'm not
totally crazy and it's very important if
you are going to do self-experimentation
or experimentation in small groups which
the Quantified Self
community did quite well and I think
still does quite well
you should really make every effort to
not fool yourself which is hard it's
it's challenging at times but read books
like bad science
read books like How to lie with
Statistics ensure that you are able to
read studies well you don't have to be
the best in the world but that you can
on some level identify the strengths and
weaknesses of studies this doesn't take
a long time certainly our friend Peter
Tia Dr Peter ortia has studying the
studies which is a multiple part blog
series dedicated to this there are other
ways to approach it I took one of his
podcasts republished it on the Tim
Ferriss show because it talked about how
to examine studies what powering refers
to things like this in the span of one
or two weeks you could really become
literate with the building blocks of
scientific literacy with respect to
reading studies and that gives you such
an enormous life Advantage it's hard to
overstate yeah I agree and I also think
that there are a lot of things that just
simply will not ever be explored in a
randomized control trial
um one of the things that Peter and I
have talked about before is he texts me
know what are your thoughts on bpc157
this is a gastric peptide that's now
been synthesized so people will inject
it into a tissue that they're trying to
heal or improve lots and lots of
anecdata on bpc157
making injuries heal faster Etc again
anecdata I've used it I took an
injection of it yesterday in fact
um
Peter basically is not a Believer
because there is a lack of published
data on this which is perfectly fine or
I should say he's um skeptical and so
there's always that possibility of a
placebo effect but I don't think there
will ever be a really nice controlled
trial on bpc157 because the financial
incentives aren't there and no smart
graduate student is going to go do a
thesis on this that so that's the
reality I mean maybe one will do it now
that we're having this conversation but
it just doesn't that the payout isn't
there yeah and that last one you
mentioned is one that people miss a lot
people doing these studies are people
with careers who are planning their
careers and so they choose what they're
going to invest time in very carefully
so that's another limiter on what we'll
end up in an RCT or not right so uh I
think that's good for people to hear
and as you get more involved with
science and in my case through a
foundation you know scissor Foundation
funding a lot of early stage science you
realize how expensive it is and how long
it takes it is a long-term investment
and if you are looking to make
behavioral changes or modify
aspects of yourself cognitive physical
psycho emotional or otherwise
identifying
interventions right options that seem to
have some plausible upside like there is
a a mechanism that might make sense in
humans
if you feel fairly certain there's very
limited downside which should include
talking to people who are presenting
their results as anecdata
then maybe
you consider using X if you can cap your
downside and I recall for instance
looking at trans Resveratrol
specifically not for longevity but in
potentially increasing endurance for for
our body
and I ended up
testing it and there's a funny story
associated with that didn't quite work
out as planned and I don't use it any
longer but what I experienced prior to
actually finding this on forums was
joint pain elbow pain the one most
consistent side effect was what felt
like tendinosis in the elbows and then I
went online
and I'd already done this but I hadn't
come across I think it was the 500
groups people have been using 500
milligrams of transverse Resveratrol
daily for long periods of time
and one of the most common reported side
effects is joint pain and I was like
okay I'm not willing to make that
trade-off yeah and that makes sense to
me yeah
I think um
it would be fun if ever you were willing
that we could do a hybrid podcast on
supplement fails I have some spectacular
failures as do I and I'm thinking I'm
thinking about a few of them I mean some
that were really
um like took me off course like there's
one supplement uh called bulbine
natalensis this is another another one
of these shrubs it sounds like an
infection I mean this thing will really
spike your testosterone and free
testosterone I'm talking back acne like
huge strange gains aggression it's
really wild and then after about seven
to ten days
it all crashes and you go below Baseline
yeah even testicular pain so it was
unclear so you if you're a smart person
you halt use right so I can understand
why people are skeptical of certain
things and then of course there are
supplements that I'm a big fan of and
that you're a big fan of we talked about
those things elsewhere but
um it might be fun to do supplement
fails podcast if ever you're willing
though I could do and just experimental
fails oh yeah yeah end of one
experimental fails which includes things
that people might not think about for
instance for our body had quite a bit
of real estate dedicated to looking at
things like PRP so completely rich
plasma I think there's a role for it
it's not useful for everything but for
certain types of engineer repair
I think it's very interesting uh but
uh every time you get injected this is
where you have to be careful because
there are very few
free lunches out there there's there's
usually some type of feedback loop your
system is very smart at Auto regulating
things this is this is outside of that a
consideration that I hadn't made which
is every time you have an injection
there's a chance of an infection
particularly if the site in my case was
the elbow and the injection was made for
the PRP
not quite where it should have been
slightly to the rear of the elbow where
this the skin is very thick and so it
pushed
staph bacteria from a mid layer of the
skin into the joint capsule not good and
that really could have ended very poorly
I ended up having to go to the ER and
get it get it all removed and so on but
that could have ended up in a in a much
much more severe
situation so you do have to be careful
with this stuff I've become a little
more conservative with someone I do
including injections I'm like all right
like let me think
twice about the injections if I'm going
to swallow something let me make sure
I'm really looking at the implications
for the liver
yeah smart very smart I'm curious about
some of the things that you talked about
in the for our body and that you've
mentioned today things like
accelerometers
continuous glucose monitors deliberate
cold exposure
how many of those things are you still
doing on a regular basis and how many do
you
um you know use a couple times a week or
a couple times a month or go through
phases of using and not using
cold exposure I use as consistently as
is practical so if I'm traveling it's a
little harder but we're in LA right now
one of the first things I did was find a
few options for contrast therapy one of
the first things I did
and by contrast I do not mean
infrared sauna and cold plunge I'd much
rather have hot and cold water just in
terms of sort of speed of heating the
Japanese approach right for just speed
of vasodilation particularly for injury
recovery
I think it's incredibly helpful for mood
regulations certainly in this case and
cold water for mood regulation or the
treatment of say depression or as a
preemptive intervention to avoid or
mitigate depression is old
used to be prescribed for melancholy and
people like the van goghs of the world
would be prescribed cold baths so that
was something I was like well
let's take a look at some of the old
history read about that and then look
into PubMed and so on to see what might
be supported so the cold I'm still using
I become increasingly interested this
was not in the four-hour body but whole
body hyperthermia often excluding the
head for
depression which I know there's some
some research yeah out of UCSF yeah
right now yeah really interesting
studies too early to report I'm not
involved in these but I think these are
really important studies because for all
the people saying oh well you know it's
ice bath stuff you know metabolism this
metabolism that but one thing that's
very clear is long-lasting very
significant increase in the
catecholamines dopamine epinephrine
norepinephrine not a replacement perhaps
for antidepressant medication but as you
said to move the needle toward
antidepressant States that's the
cocktail and
um heat as well yeah yeah and the
hyperthermia especially the way it is
formatted right now with some of the
research is is very early stages there's
going to be less adherence it's not as
readily available it's a cold shower
cold bath so I do think about the
Practical implications that but right
now it's very interesting slow carb diet
still use it all the time it is not my
default 24 7 as it used to be so maybe
I'm just getting older and more
self-indulgent but if I find myself
going off the rails a bit and I'm like
okay I'm getting closer to Muffin Top
here let's stage an intervention then I
will go immediately back to slow carb
diet and within within a matter of weeks
I it's it's pretty easily corrected and
it's just a cue for people I know it's
um you know it's slow carb diet achieved
great dominance in fact it wasn't it
featured on or mentioned in an episode
of Orange Is the New Black I think it
might have been it's made it's made
appearances on a handful of shows great
I realized that I've been referring to
the Slow Carb Diet several times
throughout this discussion so for those
that aren't familiar with the Slow Carb
Diet I know they can go look up what
that is but so that we can keep them
here sure for the rest of this
discussion and not have to send them out
and back uh just yet
um could you give us just a brief top
Contour of what the slow carb diet is
sure this is a slow carb diet is
intended to be a simple easy to adhere
to diet for people who have perhaps
failed other diets that allows you to
recompose your body so improve muscle
mass decrease
body fat percentage and the rules are
really simple and that's part of what
makes it work
it's not ideal for every sport in every
circumstance but broadly speaking it
works for a lot of people who've had
trouble with dieting in the past
so rule number one
don't drink calories
that's it very simple so black coffee
unsweetened tea great juice out anything
with calories out
you could add a little bit of heavy
cream to your coffee let's say but
that's that's also bending the rules in
a way that I don't like so in the
beginning it's like follow the rules so
you can break them later so in the
beginning let's just say you can't drink
calories number two don't eat anything
White
sounds pretty basic right just don't
need anything that is the color of white
or that could be white basically that
means you're going to be avoiding
starches and uh things that are are
similar to starches that includes things
like oatmeal that includes things like
oatmeal so roughly speaking just
avoiding things that are white or that
could be white will get you pretty far
and yes there are exceptions like
cauliflower fine you can have
cauliflower but again don't get fancy
right it's very easy to outsmart
yourself when it comes to behavioral
change keep it simple so for at least
two weeks forget about the exceptions
right
don't drink calories
don't eat anything White
and then
eat 30 grams of protein within 30
minutes of waking up okay we got that
and then there are a few buckets you can
choose from Ryan so you have vegetables
beans and lentils
uh and then some type of protein so
you're going to come up with meals that
you can follow
without deviating for a period of one or
two weeks just come up with the same
meals
and that's going to sound boring yes but
guess what you do it already you just
might not realize it
and the the lentils and the beans
specifically as a prereq
we can get into some of the reasons but
add a lot of fiber and also inhibit
appetite right so that's actually a very
important component of these meals
and there may be a handful of other
rules but those are the basics and then
the Redemption is take one day off per
week and just go crazy that's
cheat day there are some epic cheat days
out there some I've captured for myself
and anything goes when I say anything I
do mean anything so if you want to
consume multiple pizzas pints of ice
cream whatever indulge I left one out
no fruit during the week so avoid fruit
avoid fructose so
agave nectar anything that is sort of
hidden sugar avoid all that uh so no
added sweeteners obviously but avoid
avoid fruit and fructose and again it's
not going to kill you guess what if
you're from European ancestry
your ancestors did not have like
blueberries in the middle of winter
generally speaking right so you'll
you'll be fine for a few weeks and then
there's that cheat day and cheat day
anything goes the amount of damage you
can do on cheat day is pretty limited
and there are ways you can mitigate that
there's a whole chapter called damage
control in the four-hour body but
focusing just on that diet and having
one day off where you know you can do
anything means when you are controlling
yourself for those six days of the week
you're not giving up your favorite foods
forever you can even keep a list of all
things you want to eat on cheat day and
then you have free license to eat on
cheat day and that provides you with a
release valve so that you can build in
the cheating as opposed to having it
occur as a failure point
and there are a handful of other things
there if you have Domino Foods in the
house for instance if you eat a lot of
almonds or mixed nuts and you're just
going to sit there compulsively eating
them while you're sitting at your laptop
don't have what I call Domino Foods in
the house which you're going to really
create some portion control issues but
broadly speaking don't drink calories
donate things that are white
take from three categories and build
your meals out and those are the meals
that you follow do not eat fruit
or fructose and then cheat one day a
week and Saturday is a nice day for
cheat day for most folks and just to
answer some questions people are going
to have no that doesn't mean 24 hours
that you can spread out over two days
that will actually set you back but the
amount of fat that you can store in a
handful of sittings over 24 hours which
legitimately is more like 12 to 18 hours
pretty Limited
um so that's a slow grab diet
great thank you for that I also want to
ask
is it okay to take the day after cheat
day and fast or do one meal that day
when I followed the Slow Carb Diet I
benefited from it tremendously lost fat
gained muscle tons of energy sleeping
great required less caffeine all sorts
of wonderful things stable blood sugar I
felt so so good
um really enjoyed the cheat days I
really really enjoyed the GPS so much
fun um at some point there's some
gastric distress that comes from you
know not regulating intake which led me
to not want to eat the next day so I
tended to do the cheat days on Sunday in
my case and then I would fast most of
Monday just water black coffee tea and
then I might have a small meal in the
evening and then by Tuesday I was back
on the Slow Carb Diet does that seem
like a um an uh sort of a detrimental
deviation from the from the plan
I think that if that is what works for
you then that is what works for you so
this is this this low carb diet template
for me is a starting point
and generally I'll say
I think this is from Picasso right it's
like learn the rules as an amateur so
you can break them as a professional but
it's like I recommend most people kind
of stick with the format
for
a handful of weeks
and measure the results right there so
there are guidelines for how to measure
the the scale is a bit of a blunt
instrument so there are other ways but
if you're extremely overweight you can
just use the scale
and fasting I think is fine or just
ratcheting back your caloric consumption
significantly and what happens over time
for most people also is for the first
say four weeks on cheat day you're gonna
go completely insane and I remember I
was doing something much stricter called
the cyclical ketogenic diet which is a
whole separate
thing it's much more
limiting in terms of what you can eat
but I was training for ultimately the
Nationals in Chinese kickboxing this was
happening in 99
so it's training super hard I was
following a cyclical ketogenic diet
which meant I could eat very few things
but I did have this one cheat day and I
would do a glycogen depletion workout
beforehand which is one of the things
you can do to limit the damage on cheat
day do a glycogen depletion workout
beforehand and then I would just go
crazy I mean I would drive to like
Krispy Kreme by 12 donuts and they would
be gone by the time I got home and it
wasn't an hour away it was like a 10
minute drive
Donuts be gone right I would go to
Safeway and I would buy a bag of those
Fun Size Snickers and that would be just
a tiny portion of my calories stuff for
you it a lot of sweet stuff I also did
the Savory stuff I mean I had my
favorites nothing was pizza nothing was
safe nothing was safe my my Paws got
into everything
and then over time because the next day
you're gonna feel like you got hit by a
diabetic dump truck
you start ratcheting back and you're
like okay maybe I don't need to do that
maybe cheat day will just be two meals
or maybe cheat day will just be like the
pastries in the morning with the coffee
and you start to regulate a bit
generally you don't have to but over
time you generally will
and I think after you've followed it to
the T just follow the Commandments for
say four to eight weeks then you can
certainly deviate and I'm not saying if
you're not hungry don't eat however in
many cases people have
they have acclimated to not eating in
the morning
and then they end up overeating later in
the day if you have that habit right if
you're consuming 50 of your calories or
more at dinner
and you want to lose body fat I would
say
get some cottage cheese or something
that will give you 30 grams easily in
the morning worst case scenario use a
protein of some type just don't make it
hyperchloric I mean powdered protein
like could be powdered powdered whey
protein whole food is going to do a lot
more
and no calorie counting correct no
calorie count
it tends to be self-limiting when you're
eating this much fiber and this much
protein
it tends to be very self-limiting what
you'll want to consume and what you can
consume
once again I had great experiences with
slow carb diet and I'm going to go back
on yeah nobody and nobody needs to buy
anything to figure it out if you just
search on tim.blog slow carb diet there
you'll get everything that you need
to get started no purchase necessary
well it works very very well I'll say
that and it's very straightforward to
follow and it does include the the
notorious uh cheat day uh Infamous cheat
day
um uh and it can be done
um on a on a very reasonable budget and
so if people want to learn more about
that they should go to Tim's blog on
four hour uh um for our body and slow
carb diet we'll provide a link yeah but
it's you know I think it's worth
highlighting again just how effective
that is you know as you pointed out
thousands and thousands of people
um using it to great success some of
whom were um quite obese and um yeah any
updates on those folks are they still
keeping the weight off I would like to
do a follow-up uh it's I think with
diets in general
there's a lot of reversion to the mean
you know regression to the means so I
would expect that that some have kept it
off and some have not that would be true
of I think every possible diet
especially for people who are overcoming
behavioral inertia of having gained
hundreds of pounds but I'd like to do
some follow-up what was fun about the
post I put together called how to lose
100 pounds on the Slow Carb Diet we had
we profiled say four or five people but
there were dozens and dozens and dozens
and dozens and this was a very long time
ago so
I would say that
a long-term follow-up would be super
interesting and that we did at one point
track several thousand people through a
platform at the time I think it was
coach.me
as they followed the soda curb diet for
the first sort of four to 12 weeks and
that was fascinating because I want the
data and I'm happy to be proven
incorrect with any of my assumptions I
mean I I don't view that as a failure I
mean I view that as a huge net gain and
uh it has a very high adherence rate so
I I pay attention to not just is
something effective does it get you the
outcome you want not only is it
efficient from a time and resource
perspective but how high is the
adherence rate right so if you take a
random sampling of a thousand people
from the US across the social economic
classes Etc how many people
practically speaking will be able to are
willing to follow this for say an
eight-week period of time or four week
period of time and I try to optimize for
the widest adherence because I know the
Slow Carb Diet people come on they're
like but what about intermittent fasting
what about this and what about endurance
athletes I'm like this is not for
everybody in all cases it just happens
to be a good default diet with a high
adherence rate and like you said it's
very inexpensive it can be followed very
very inexpensively I just sorry to
interrupt you one thing that I really
like about it is that many variants on
caloric restriction which is because
laws of thermodynamics definitely apply
yes we're not we're not trying to say
they don't
um but one of the issues with a lot of
things including intermittent fasting
which I sort of do some very end of
because I'm not really hungry to eat
until about 11 I like to train in the
morning if I can Etc
is that they can sometimes prevent best
performance in terms of especially
resistance training high intensity
resistance training so very low carb
diets I've tried them even if you're
paying attention to you know other ways
to restock glycogen performance drops
off whereas a slow carb diet I feel like
I can think
I can work I can exercise I can sleep
like everything just works well but
there's one thing in it that I want to
raise it when I heard this I thought
there's no way this is true which was uh
making sure that you get 30 or so grams
of protein within 30 minutes of waking
yeah and I thought how can that be like
how can adding protein early in the day
actually make a difference and it really
did work I was I still track my numbers
so in terms of dropping body fat
percentage increasing muscle it really
does work now whether or not that's
simply because it's offsetting food
intake that I would have
um food that I would have taken in later
in the day I don't know and I don't I'm
not going to make myself my own control
experiment to the point that I drive
myself crazy but it really does work
quite well
um to get past sticking points you just
get that 30 grams of protein early so
sort of violate the the time restricted
feeding component deliberately with some
protein in the morning then still train
and do all the other things and you know
carry on as usual and it's just so it
seems so peculiar like eating more and
and losing body fat but it works yeah
it's counterintuitive and a lot of
approaches can work for a lot of
different people right to State the
obvious but this particular aspect of
this low carb diet
is helpful for let's just say the
majority of the people in that thousand
person sample I was talking about the
hypothetical pull from different parts
of say the us or anywhere
because it it it seems to help with a
few things first there's just the
thermic effect of food and for protein
there's a greater thermic effect you
also have and I think there's there's
decent at the time there was decent
literature to support this so I don't
know if it's changed that the protein
intake
along those lines has an appetite
suppressing effect so the The Net Daily
calories consumed tends to be less when
someone has a higher protein meal
earlier in the day and last but not
least I will say one of the risks and
there are many people who execute well
on this but you have to be very
meticulous which is true of the
ketogenic diet as well you can get
yourself into a lot of trouble if you do
it 60 right or 70 right you're really in
there you can get yourself in their
massive psoriasis I mean my scalp you
know sloughing off like when I'm in
ketosis like I'm like what the hell is
going on here going back on some complex
carbohydrates and going away yeah
exactly yeah I don't need I don't need a
randomized control trial no I simply
don't want to run that experiment
against your scalp you know so in the
case of say time restricted feeding
some people who do intermittent fasting
lose a lot of muscle mass and there are
multiple reasons for this I think people
should make use of relatively widely
available tools like dexa and so on to
ensure that your composition is actually
moving the way you think it's moving
make sure you standardize your hydration
for that as well as time of day just Pro
tip that's true for blood tests as well
but
it seems to get net net better effects
than trying to teach people how to fast
effectively which you can do and we can
talk about fasting that's something that
was not included in the four-hour body
that were I to rewrite it today I would
include a section and there was a bit in
tools of Titans to address that on more
extended fasts let's just call it three
to seven day fasts uh so that's an area
that's of of great interest to me as is
ketosis and metabolic Psychiatry I'll uh
Chris Palmer who we both know incredible
I mean what he's what the Awakening that
he's created through his book and going
on your podcast my podcast and others
and and you know
letting people be aware that changes in
diet can impact mental health so I think
in two three years it's going to be a
duh and we're not just talking about the
difference between you know um slamming
back horrible Foods horrible Forest
Foods versus eating really clean I mean
really specific diet protocols to treat
mental health yeah incredible yeah super
excited so that's that's one of the
things that I'm paying a lot of
attention to right now they're a handful
in that realm within the just say the
the interplay of Mind and Body since the
Cartesian Duality and separation of this
too makes no sense from a biological
standpoint so that's that's something
that certainly captured my attention and
I paid a lot of attention to even as far
back as early 2000s for mental health
and just cognitive performance I'd like
to take a quick break and thank our
sponsor inside tracker inside tracker is
a personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
help you reach your health goals I've
long been a believer in getting regular
blood work done for the simple reason
that many of the factors that impact
your immediate and long-term Health can
only be assessed with a quality blood
test the problem with a lot of blood and
DNA tests out there however is that
they'll give you information about
certain lipid markers or hormone markers
but no information about what to do with
all of that data inside tracker makes it
very easy to look at your levels of
hormones metabolic factors lipids Etc
and then to assess what sorts of
Behavioral nutritional supplementation
or perhaps other interventions you might
want to use in order to bring those
numbers into the ranges that are optimal
for your health for this week only the
week of June 19 2023 inside tracker is
offering a buy one get one free on their
ultimate plan this is their best
discount of the year you can get this
offer by going to insidetracker.com
huberman again that's inside tracker.com
huberman
thanks for revisiting some of the four
hour body and slow carb diet and
elaborating on some of the process that
went into that and I think creators of
all kinds thinkers of all kinds and
people who are interested in the
contents of the four hour body are going
to be very grateful for that information
I certainly am fascinated by your
process one of the things that you
mentioned along the lines of process was
you know
the power of places and where one
happens to live I think there's a essay
by Paul Graham that talks about this
it's a little outdated
um you know and it talks about the
messages that you
um the tacit messages of being in
certain cities I think it was you know
like Boston you're not smart enough
um uh what was it was New York uh you're
not powerful enough uh and not you
obviously I just thinking and um or you
should be more powerful is the message
like the tacit message um Los Angeles
um what you're what you're doing people
aren't paying attention paying enough
attention to it something like that like
don't asset messages these are
stereotypes about cities certainly
cities change
um the role of places is an interesting
one like you know you mentioned you know
small gathering Kevin Kelly's house
Quantified Self and I think for people
who don't know people like that right
um maybe we could
get your thoughts on you how would one
think about where to live and and maybe
even curating their own Gatherings
useful Gatherings because it's not that
uh I have to imagine it's not that you
guys sat back and you're like I'm Tim
Ferriss and he's like I'm Kevin Kelly
let's have a gathering so we can talk
about it in a few years on a podcast
this stuff happens
um that word you know it's dangerous
word organically
um
when people who have common interests
decide to get together and talk and
listen and brainstorm and I'm yet to do
that in a you know with good people and
not
have something really incredible come
out of it not necessarily that day yeah
but looking five years looking back five
years later and just going God that was
really worthwhile totally yeah
a few thoughts in no particular order I
would say the first is it depends my
recommendations depend a lot on where
you are in the Arc of your career in
life if you are
in full growth
hyperdrive mode and you are trying to
build both yourself and your
capabilities in a very concentrated way
where you're not necessarily focused on
family you maybe have fewer obligations
then if you're serious I think many
people should consider moving to an area
of high density
for a period of time it could be three
months it could be six months
could be longer but putting yourself in
a New York or an LA or a San Francisco
or Chicago or as new places develop I'll
give you one you might not expect same
Ottawa Canada where Shopify is based and
the presence and growth of Shopify has
spawned an entire ecosystem of startups
so there may be options outside of the
usual cast of characters
Pittsburgh and Duolingo similar effect
so there are more options than people
might recognize but
taking a journey and placing yourself
in a place where you can be in a very
active pinball machine where you may
interact serendipitously with many
different people from many different
worlds I think is in is is hard to
overstate the value of
and my
drive and my filtering function let's
just say because when I first got to the
Bay Area nobody cared about me I was
nobody I was driving my mom's used
minivan hand-me-down that had the seats
stolen out of the back were you in the
South Bay I was I was working in San
Jose
yeah I mean no disrespect to San Jose
I'm from the South Bay yeah but there's
a there's a bleakness to the South there
is there is a little bit of bleakness
and then I lived across the street in
this tiny apartment lived across the
street from the Jack in the Box in
Mountain View so it's not like I was
strolling onto the big stage and just
blowing people away oh I I I I grew up
right near Mountain View I'm very
familiar I probably skated the curves of
that jacket are you trained at the
Gold's Gym in off ring store it did
actually amazing yeah that was a great
gym that was a great gym that's a great
gym I don't think it's still going to go
there super late before my writing
sessions and it had the benefit of being
open really really late and wow rank
story I haven't thought about that in a
long time so the point is I also started
where a lot of people are starting
and what did I do
I put myself in a high density
environment
next what did I do knowing no one I
started to volunteer
at events where they had interesting
speakers and interesting people coming
to hear those speakers so I put myself
in Silicon Valley and then I began
volunteering for groups like s vase I
don't know if it exists anymore the
Silicon Valley Association of startup
entrepreneurs I think it was hi the in
this entrepreneur which is a very sort
of Indian or indian-american focused
organization that does a lot in the
realm of startups
and I would carry water I would take out
garbage I would check name badges I
would check people in nothing was too
low for me and I'll give you guys a tip
that will be obvious to some but
non-obvious to many
when you're volunteering a lot of folks
who volunteer do the absolute bare
minimum because they are not getting
paid
this is not going to get you noticed but
it sets a very low bar so that if you
volunteer at these events and someone's
dropping the ball or there's something
happening that needs fixing and you just
proactively do it the producers of these
events will notice you and this is what
happened over time over a few months and
then I got invited to join in on
meetings that were planning future
events and I eventually got to the point
where I was recruiting speakers and able
to set the agenda for an entire main
event
and then that's how I got to know say
Jack Canfield who is the co-creator of
Chicken Soup for the Soul and many
others who introduced me to my book
agent many many many many years later
Jack Canfield
but I was a nobody then you have to play
the long game
but you can be methodical on how you
play that and that is one approach just
as an example
for how to build your network which
snowballs over time don't hump every
vip's leg within 10 minutes of meeting
them
play it cool you know in the Gatherings
where that person is uh has a lot of
Demands on them is the last place you
want to do that right the way you're
going to make yourself most saliency to
that yeah the way you're going to make
yourself memorable with people like that
is to be very professional always on
time
predict what they are going to need or
problems they'll run into beforehand and
address them before they even think of
them and be easy to deal with
and
people like that high performers notice
these things they will make note of it
yeah the being easy to work with is
something that
um
I used to tell my graduate students in
postdocs I mean because the opposite of
that nobody wants yeah right nobody
wants that yeah especially in the
beginning like later okay great your
Steve Jobs you want to be difficult here
and there or a lot no problem yeah right
but in the beginning that can be a real
liability
you can make up for that if you are the
best in the world but in the very
beginning you probably won't be uh so
try to stack the deck in your favor
volunteering is a shortcut and that
would be one way of doing it another now
especially given the virtual communities
that exist so you have subreddits you
have online communities you have Twitter
groups you have Clubhouse you've got a
million different options which can be
overwhelming Clubhouse still going maybe
not I have no idea oh no I don't know
I'm not saying it's gone I just I
remember during the pandemic there were
some Clubhouse Gatherings that hopped on
there and but I've sort of forgotten to
together the the platform Affinity is
really fickle which is why I think to
the extent possible if you want to build
a world-class and I use that term very
deliberately
Network in record time just to give you
a nice headline I would say focus on the
uncrowded channel which is in person
it's out of fashion it's out of Vogue
going to a conference and actually
interacting with humans in the hallway
approaching panelists this is another
thing that I did I'll give it I'll give
another tip so very early on I would go
to conferences nobody cared who I was
nobody knew who it was fine and
I would study the panels let's say I'm
going to a big event like South by
Southwest
and I would this is what I did in 2007
which was just prior to the first book
coming out
and I would go to these various
in-person events I was focused mostly on
events that had uh the Thematic focus of
blogs we could come back that but blogs
were what podcasts were a few years ago
right they drove incredible traffic but
they were undervalued by mainstream
media undervalued by mainstream
Publishers Etc which meant there was an
Arbitrage opportunity in a way
and I would pick say a handful of
panels with topics I thought were super
interesting
and then the panel would end and what
would happen the panelists would get
rushed
by various folks because many of them
were well known who was not getting
rushed the moderator
I would go straight to the moderator and
I would talk to the moderator I'd thank
them for the panel I would be very
genuine none of it was made up and
talked them for a bit they generally
ask why I was there what I was
interested in I would mention whatever
that happened to be in this case it was
I'm finishing my first book where I had
my first book coming out soon I'm here
to hopefully meet people
who are involved with a b or c and then
if we hit it off which was not true
every time but if it seemed to be going
well I would say is I don't know anyone
here
I'm really sort of orphaned here making
my way through
uh this entire event is there anyone
else here you think I would get along
with who maybe I could buy a drink or
coffee and the vast majority of the time
they'd be like oh yeah you should meet
so and so and then I get the
introduction and then I would meet that
person I would have a genuine
interaction with that person and if it
made sense if things were going well I'd
do the same thing
is there anybody else here you think I
should just say hi to and I get along
with not who I can ask for something
and that wasn't deception I was being
honest like someone I could actually
Vibe with and if so would you mind
making the intro oh yeah sure no problem
many of those people are still my
friends
and by being surgical in that way not
trying to gather business cards to use a
really Antiquated
metaphor yeah people still hand them out
I guess depends on where you are
especially like Boston but uh if if
rather than trying to collect people as
Pokemon cards
developing say five three to five
deeper relationships through longer
conversations at an event that is what
directly LED ultimately to the hockey
stick for the four hour work week within
Tech within specifically San Francisco
so those would be a few approaches for
for building your network when you don't
have the ability to just walk up to say
Kevin Kelly and have a conversation that
came over time
yeah whether or not it's Health
practices or uh nutritional practices or
at meetings seems you're oriented toward
the uncrowded but very interesting
people in spaces but the key word there
I think is uncrowded and of course the
other keyword is interesting right I
mean it's not like you're standing in
the parking lot talking to whoever
happens to be there although that can be
interesting right there's a Serendipity
there and you know there's always things
to learn from people but in terms of
career advancement and and building new
ideas and foraging for information I'm
just struck how you've done that over
and over
um and again thank you for giving us
some insight into the process please uh
here's another one so I think there's a
tendency among people who want to
develop their Networks
or their relationships
to be not to get too
technical but that's a technical term
yeah yeah
and they want to tell other people they
are friends with someone more than they
want to develop skills or learn from
someone
this puts you in a very disadvantaged
position
because then that means all right you
want to become friends with Elon Musk
good luck
or you want to become friends with this
a-lister celebrity who everyone else
wants to meet good luck it's going to be
a crowded bloody path to get there
and by the way they've also certainly
developed really attuned defenses
against people like you I guess so it's
going to be hard on the other they have
staff to prevent oh yeah they have a
Phalanx of protectors to prevent you
from ever getting to that person
on the other hand if you're approaching
it from the standpoint of developing
skills learning and actually becoming
potential friends with someone
give you an example
you could go after you want to become
better at
boxing let's just make that up all right
maybe not the greatest example skiing
would be another one but let's let's
stick with boxing just because of the
way I'll explain it if you wanted to say
get personalized lessons from Floyd
Mayweather ain't gonna happen
okay let's go then maybe a step down out
of the pro ranks to gold medalist okay
if it's brand new gold medalist let's
just say like Oscar De La Hoya when he
was really The Golden Boy and it just
thrashed everyone still going to be hard
what about the silver medalist who just
had a bad day
when he had that last bout against Oscar
De La Hoya potentially right from a
technical perspective
from a personal connection perspective
you may have more in common with that
person or a bronze medalist and they can
get you 70 80 90 of the way there and by
the way you probably don't have the
physical attributes to make to 100
anyway
if you're coming to it this late
and
you could get in many cases one-on-one
lessons whether in person or virtually
with someone who is of that caliber
they're in the same front of the pack as
the names I just mentioned maybe not as
famous
100 bucks 200 bucks per hour
for a lot of people that is Within Reach
and I'm not sure what the value of
saying one knows somebody very famous is
it's just never been something I've
oriented to it's a common orientation
though yeah and I think that's true for
a lot of things like many people use say
psychedelics because they want to tell
other people the story
that they have of doing psychedelics
right they're not doing it intrinsically
for what they hope to get out of that
experience maybe there's part of them
but it's more the social signaling and
validation they get when they project
that out at a group dinner into a story
that they can tell and that's true for
many things so one of the questions I
ask myself with all sorts of things if I
could never talk about this would I do
it
what a great
great right thing to think about right
like if I could if I could have let's
just say we didn't know each other and I
was like okay
I'm earlier in my career let's apply
some constraints so I'm not where I am I
still want to do a b and c in the public
eye maybe I want to build a podcast
whoever
if I could meet with you but I could
never tell a soul
would I do it I don't know would you I
would thank you I would but I would too
but but for a lot of folks if they
meaning I'd meet with you I'm not saying
I'd meet with me by the way
that'd be with me you know the believe
me I meet with me all the time and
sometimes it's pretty unpleasant yeah
and and that can be applied to all sorts
of things right it's like and it's it's
a useful question because I asked myself
this
for examining your motivations and I'm
not saying one motivation is always
better than another but it's it's you
should at least be aware of your driving
motivations because you can end up
playing games you're not even aware
you're playing and that's how you end up
I think getting into a lot of trouble in
life one of the ways so that would be a
question I might apply I apply other
questions like there's a great question
uh that Seth Godin applies who really I
admire tremendously and has built an
incredibly
unorthodox unique life for himself and
his family he's he's zigged when
everyone would expect him to zag and I I
and he always has a defensible logic
behind it and much like Derek sivers but
most people have probably heard the
hypothetical question like what would
you do if you knew you couldn't fail
right or what would you do if you
couldn't fail and Seth turns that around
I think that's a good question but he
turns around he said what would you do
if you knew you were gonna fail
in terms of identifying what you would
do for the process
right what would you do if you knew it
was going to fail okay you're
considering these five different
projects let's say they're all going to
fail but you still have to choose one of
the five
which would you choose yeah that's a
great question
um
much harder to answer yeah and you know
at the same time I'm called back to uh
when I was a graduate student and still
now with the podcast uh I have this um
litmus test which is you know is the
experiment that I'm working on
the one that I want to be working on
most is the podcast that I'm working on
most I mean there's truly no other
podcast I'd rather be having today than
this one right and the moment I'm
starting to think oh I wish I was doing
that thing over there I realize I'm off
Target I'm off Target and um I think
that asking really good questions is
something clearly that you're very good
at and uh getting a little bit deeper
into your process around that do you
write those things down like is there a
Notebook someplace in the Kingdom of uh
of Tim Ferriss in Austin or elsewhere
um that says you know those questions
that that essentially those questions
are written are they yeah I literally
have a document with questions that I've
gathered from Seth printed out and at
the Airbnb where I'm staying here so I
brought it with you I printed it out
here and then I went through and I read
it last night and I was highlighting
questions from past interviews I've had
with him on my podcast to revisit his
questions
so I I was literally doing that last
night over dinner and I collect
questions I collect questions if I am
reading a magazine and I come across a
good question I take I take a photo or I
capture it somehow in notes or in
Evernote which I know is kind of
old-fashioned these days but I've used
it for everything so the critical masses
and Beyond enormous and I do collect and
revisit these things I capture them in
journals as well but I I absolutely
capture good questions when I find them
questions are so powerful for the brain
I don't want to go into this in too much
detail because I have a lot more
questions for you but uh we just wrapped
a series on Mental Health that will come
out later this year with Paul conti and
he um is brilliant as we both know and
uh does truly important work and
um and he pointed to the value of asking
really good questions about oneself and
because of the way that
questions that are really directed at
self-inquiry cue up the subconscious so
you ask the question and unlike a
statement or a meme
um the brain works with that in the days
and hours after asking the question in
ways that
um simple declarative statements
probably don't ping the system the same
way which is probably why we can see so
many points of wisdom and Truth
everywhere and it doesn't necessarily
transform us but asking really good
questions really does seem to transform
us yeah there's uh
I think judging people by their
questions is
it's also a shortcut to assessing and
learning a lot about how someone
functions and what makes them tick
I think this will Tara who said you know
judge a man by his questions by his
answers something along those lines but
when in doubt attribute to Voltaire it
sounds good does sound good and I think
about this a lot I do think about the
questions and I refine the questions
that I ask myself especially while
journaling because it's easier to
cross-examine and stress test your own
certainty and beliefs when they are
captured on paper
or
digitally on a laptop for instance so I
I do
routinely revisit certain questions that
I found
helpful over time I mean one that people
can play with is with whatever is really
causing you consternation or stress at
the moment some kind of decision a
relationship
business could be anything just what
might this look like if it were easy
right what might this look like if it
were easy if it had to be easy if that
were possible what might it look like
and that could apply to anything I could
apply to anything you know could apply
to could apply Fitness it's like look if
you do really intense kettlebell swings
twice a week with proper weight and load
and time under tension and you do
push-ups a few times a week and handle a
couple of other
elements you can get in pretty good
shape it's so simple but
hits a lot I mean hits your entire
posterior chain okay fine do some
push-ups and some core work
but if you're not exercising at all
because you've made the assumption that
it's
four hours five hours a week rather than
completely remove that objective
and call it
just impractical can you ratchet down
the scale how far can you ratchet down
the scale until you have no excuses all
right
I'll just be one one example language
learning Tech investing it applies to
everything
yeah making life easier is something
that definitely gets my vote yeah making
it easier and making it more elegant
right the more pieces in your life you
have floating around the more context
the more extraneous loose connections
the harder your life is going to be the
cognitive overload or overhead is really
high so I'm always looking for maybe
like Japanese
in a flower ranger it's like okay how
many pieces can I remove while still
like maintaining the essence of what I'm
trying to achieve you and Rick Rubin man
I'm telling you you know two people I am
fortunate enough to know personally and
that I have tremendous respect for and
you know the work and uh is self-evident
you know it's really remarkable so uh
rewind that and listen to that segment
right there folks I'm telling you I've
worked hard to apply it because it's not
my default and boy does it make a
significant Improvement to simplify
simplify simplify take some thought and
question asking it's like you just can't
delete things at random so you get down
to some fixed number but
um I'd like to ask you about another
area where you really have seemed to see
around corners and this is one that
actually carried with it significant
risk
um not necessarily risk to health into
life
but risk in terms of outside perceptions
and that's psychedelics as you know I've
substantially changed my view on this uh
we don't need to go into my former
stance on I talked about that when you
were gracious enough to host me on your
podcast for a second time uh I'd done
some psychedelics recreationally as a
kid it was correlated with not so great
times in my life stayed away from them
then eventually Revisited MDMA in
particular from a therapeutic standpoint
found tremendous benefit again
therapeutically with a medical doctor
again these drugs are illegal soon to
change perhaps hopefully and we'll talk
about that but uh it's becoming clear
from the controlled Studies by Robin
Carter Harris there are many others okay
Nolan Williams others that these drugs
have enormous potential to help relieve
depression trauma
help people explore their psyche their
mind for sake of feeling better doing
better in the world for leaning into
life not tune in drop out but
um you know to really lean into life
with more purpose and more satisfaction
in some cases they've really have saved
lives I think um
what was your mindset around
psychedelics when you first started
exploring them what
what led you to overcome the inevitable
you know fear Gap there
because you do seem like somebody who
takes value in your health right you're
not Reckless you may have been more
adventurous in the past with things like
I hate the word but biohacking and
self-experimentation than you are now
but but you obviously have some
self-preservation mechanism intact we
learn we learn we learn
um what was your mindset around at the
time and then I want to get to what
you've learned from it
um and frankly the tremendous
efforts that you've put that are now
translating to tremendous value for
really millions of people and ultimately
I think it's going to be billions of
people
um by establishing funding for the
pioneering research in this area helping
to promote the movement of these
compounds from illegal to legal in the
therapeutic setting
so on and so on so take us back to
um your first thoughtful exploration of
psychedelics what'd that look like
you're like oh mushrooms I'll eat them
was that it or was it
um or was it a a dedicated research
process and who'd you talk to what was
it all about
so let's go way back to my undergrad
experience and
there are many reasons that I ended up
going to Princeton I think I was very
lucky to get in my SAT scores because I
can never finish the damn test I have so
much of a perfectionist I get stuck and
ended up not doing terribly well but
through essays and other things
ultimately was able to go part of the
job let me interrupt you and just say I
think at this point we can say they were
lucky to have you well thank you for
saying that yeah thank you for saying
yeah great institution you've done great
and you're a a great um uh poster on the
wall for them yeah oh really I hope so
really really yeah I I just want to say
it because you're not going to and I
think it's important that these are
great institutions of great minds go
through there and
that you know Einstein went through
there yeah and uh and their success
rests not just on the Einsteins but also
on the student body and what they go out
into the world and do and not just in
the realm of science so yeah really
they're lucky to have had you yeah thank
you Andrew I studied Chinese in a room
where Einstein used to teach it's pretty
cool to set foot and spend time weekly
in a space that was shared by some of
these people amazing it really it really
gets the imagination firing
if we go back to that chapter in my life
I was initially a Psychology major with
focus on Neuroscience so I wanted to be
a neuroscientist and there are many
reasons for that I have
neurodegenerative disease on both sides
of my family so Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's
so that was certainly a personal driving
interest
in terms of looking at mechanisms
understanding what Therapeutics existed
or did not exist how things were
developing in the research
and while I was there
which later I ended up Switching gears
and transferring to focus on language
acquisition and East Asian studies hence
the Chinese that I mentioned earlier and
Japanese and Korean but on the
Neuroscience side
or a lot of cool breakthroughs also that
came out of uh Princeton around that
time looking at the amazing discovery of
say uh neuronal uh
I want to say Regenesis but neurogenesis
in the hippocampus exactly yeah exactly
so there was quite a bit happening at
that time I was a subject I loved
volunteering for studies just to try to
get an inside look at how things were
done in some of Daniel kahneman's
experiments so it was a cool time to be
there and
within the first two years I want to say
I had my first experience recreationally
with mushrooms
and
Looking Back Now I mean I'm horrified by
the lack of control and meaning not
control but lack of supervision right I
mean the setting the set and setting
ended up being fine nothing terrible
happened but there were a lot of ways it
could have gone sideways but that first
experience and I must have consumed in
retrospect just a dizzying amount of
mushrooms I mean it might be in excess
of five grams it would have been more
yeah just knowing what I know now it
would have been kids don't do this at
all don't do that I'm not I'm not gonna
say don't do it at home don't do it at
all yeah yeah please I don't think I
actually don't think uh the young
developing brain should be exposed to
psychedelics we could talk we could talk
about that yeah I'm gonna take my stance
I'm gonna take it for now yeah I mean in
in the world in which we live in the US
um I would I would totally agree with
you
um there are some interesting cultural
exceptions in other places uh where
there things are more set up to
provide for that type of use but I
certainly would not recommend it but but
coming back to my my recreational
experience my my subjective experience
was so bizarre
and my experience of time so non-linear
my experience of self
so different from anything I had
experienced up to that point
and therefore my construction of reality
being so completely unlike anything
I had experienced was enough to make me
want to learn about these compounds and
very early on
still have a scan of it somewhere I
think it was in 1998 or 99 I actually
wrote a paper one of my junior papers
was focused on examining potential
similarities between REM sleep and
LSD
lsd25 and
looking at some of the patterns of of
neural activity of course we can do a
lot more now with with the tools we have
available but from a scientific
perspective I was very curious about how
much we knew
and how much we didn't know and I would
say that latter category gets me more
excited in a way and I'm like okay
how how much room is there for growth
here right because if if we're just
putting on the finishing touches with
marginal you know incremental
improvements on something that we feel
like we've largely figured out that's
less interesting to me than something
that baffles most people examining them
on some level
and there was a professor named Barry
Jacobs who was doing some very
interesting work he did a lot of work
looking at the
serotonergic systems and uh did a lot of
work with cats ultimately I could not do
personally the animal work required of
the sort of indentured servitude that I
would I think he wrote someplace once
you know you you said you know when
confronted with the uh the prospect of
installing a a computer printer into the
header jacket on the back of a cat head
they totally had those like those little
VGA ports on the back of these cats
heads because cats sleep a lot and so
they're interesting to study yeah a lot
of that cats very few Laboratories work
on cats any longer it's mostly a mouse
still some non-human primate work my
laboratory is essentially shut down
um or is in the process of shutting down
even our Mouse work I'd much prefer to
work on humans they can give consent and
they house themselves and um the animal
research thing is tough for any for any
sentient being yeah it's tough for what
it's worth the cats seem pretty happy
like they were just sleeping I mean the
the ports were for tracking so the cats
were pretty I mean they were just normal
cats the cats were fine but I would have
been we would have been injecting
retroviruses into rats and then
perfusing them which means bleeding them
to death uh to avoid bruising of the
tissue because then if you're going to
take thin slices and scans you didn't
want to have bruising and and I just
couldn't I just couldn't do it I think
it's important I do think
I do think there's a place for it but I
couldn't do it so that's why I
transferred out but the the point I was
trying to make is that I had the
experience and then I had that drive the
scientific interest
and then I had a probably one experience
per year
for a few years after that and
what I noticed for myself personally
because I've suffered from major
depressive disorder an extended
depressive episodes let's just say on
average three to four a year and by by
extended even before you had started
even before from a young age yeah from
very young age and I would say so let's
just call it three to four on average a
year those could last each a few weeks
or a few months I mean this is this is a
a very high percentage my total year
and when I had these higher dose
experiences with with mushrooms so we're
talking about philosophy mushrooms and
then if we're looking at the molecule
that's being examined scientifically
psilocybin
I noticed this Afterglow effect that was
really durable and that that was an
antidepressant effects or a mood
elevating effect that lasted far longer
than the half-life could explain right
because it's four to six hours you're
you're kind of on the other side
and I would experience this this
Afterglow effect for three to six months
and that raised all sorts of interesting
questions
what the hell is going on here is it the
content is it some structural change
there were a lot of unanswered questions
for me and then I had a very very scary
experience that led me to completely
stop use of psychedelics where again
uncontrolled environment ended up in
rural uh in rural New York coming out of
my trip standing in the middle of the
road in the middle of the night with
headlights coming at me goodness
gracious so you don't want to do that
yeah and I was like okay too dangerous
were you taking them alone is that how
that is taking them with two friends and
my two friends without telling me just
went for a walk and left me alone
these are powerful compounds yeah you're
you're playing with nuclear power like
these these are the this is the nuclear
power of
like psychological or
uh psycho-emotional surgery is is the
way I encourage people to think about
them
and I stopped using any psychedelics
completely I was still very interested
in them and but I basically hit pause
and I didn't revisit that until let's
call it 2012 2013 where I was still
struggling with major depression
disorder and I saw my girlfriend at the
time completely transformed by
supervised facilitated use of in this
case Ayahuasca which was not quite as
common as it is in conversation
at the time
and she did that in South America but
she
not only explained her experience but I
was able to see the transformation in
her that seemed to have some durability
over time and that is when I started
stepping back into
researching psychedelics looking at what
had been published in the last let's
just call it 10 years as at that point
in time and
thinking about how I would approach it
systematically
with safeguards with proper supervision
and basically approaching it the way I
would have approached any of the topics
in the for our body
and that is what led me back into along
with a number of other interventions I
should say so I wasn't betting the farm
on psychedelics I also started TM at
that point I was I was skewed yourself
some people might uh trans uh
transcendental medications these are
like four to ten day meditation Retreats
this was actually much shorter it was a
two or three day training and you're
visiting the instructor I want to say
it's once or twice a day probably once a
day and getting up to speed and I did
this because I was going through a
period of acute stress this is finishing
the four hour chef
this is actually probably in the Years
preceding that and I had one friend who
I'd seen really change from let's just
call hyperkinetic high anxiety to low
anxiety and he said you have the time
you have the money pay for the course
just take it yes there are all these
criticisms of TM yes there are all these
weird historical anecdotes of people
trying to levitate and all this
weirdness just ignore that I'm trying to
levitate if you actually levitate then
we got to have a discussion it seems
like yeah why not you know every kid
every kid tries all sorts of things give
it a go uh he's like just put that aside
because I kept coming up with pushback
and he's like look
all I'm saying is it's like a warm bath
for your mind that you take twice a day
and it'll chill you the out so try
it and I was like okay fine it's a good
endorsement I was like I was like at
this point I was I had been burning the
candle at both ends so intensely it's
like okay so there's TM and then I began
examining how I might approach notice I
didn't just jump into using them I was
like how could I approach taking
psychedelics in a sequence in a logical
sequence
with proper protections with safety
assurances and that took me
probably a month or two and I was right
in the middle of things in Northern
California you have access to a lot
and only then did I start looking at
having my own experiences and lo and
behold I mean I'll I'll cut to the chase
but the the personal
outcome and there are many
different benefits and risks I should
make very clear these things can be
extremely dangerous in certain ways
generally not physiologically but they
can be dangerous
I would say instead of three to four
times per year on average I probably
have one depressive episode every two
years that's a significant Improvement
right I mean from a quality of life
perspective those are two different
people
and uh that then led me to and I as I
did with all my workouts right I took
copious notes over the span I mean now
we're looking at 10 plus years uh so if
I were to ever write another book uh it
would probably be related to all of the
really
fine details of the experiments and my
learnings including some of the more
bizarre things over the last 10 years
but it would be a it would be just a
beast to create so with with
psychedelics experiences with
psychedelics psychedelics and sort of
psychedelic adjacent uh non-ordinary
experiences of Consciousness which I
think often are touching at edges of the
same thing uh which which is going to be
controversial for some folks but to to
come back to the storyline just to put a
bow on that
when I saw the personal outcomes for me
the anecdata from friends who are
facilitators who have worked with
thousands of people right which is a
pretty good sample size still anecdote
but these are people who are very smart
who keep records and I believe that
these people have spotted patterns that
are only going to be possible to test
and verify over the next five to ten
years so I at least as a
is a means of generating hypotheses I
take these people very seriously uh
and then I started to connect with
Scientists whose work I had read like
Roland Griffiths at Johns Hopkins
began looking at the most compelling
data related to say MDMA assisted
Psychotherapy and
complex PTSD
I I made the
commitment to myself that as soon as I
had enough money to move the dial
because I really felt like these tools
were so outside of the normal Paradigm
of
Psychiatry and pharmacology
and that made me very excited because it
was uncrowded there was very little
funding coming into the space
it was high leverage and I looked at it
just as I've looked at my many startup
Investments uh limited downside risk
really high upside potential and I
should say before that I had already
been funding in a very small way science
so the first check I ever wrote was
personally to Adam gazzali's Lab at UCSF
yeah great lab which at the time
was looking at software he's not going
to like this description that I'm going
to simplify it software that might
attenuate or reverse age-related
cognitive impairment uh specifically
related to various aspects of of
attention and
that was my first foray into funding
early stage science which was very
analogous to me of uh to funding early
stage startups and then later on to
touch on the reputational thing I know
this is a TED talk so thank you for
listening no this is great please please
uh you're always so gracious on your
podcast this is what people want this is
certainly what I want to hear so so on
the reputational side you're right that
at the time especially let's just call
it 2013 to 2015 this was not a Nat a
comfortable National conversation of any
type yeah I wouldn't have had this
conversation back then no way I'd lose I
don't know that I would have lost my job
it just would have raised a lot of
eyebrows and now such studies are
happening yeah the perception yeah the
perception was
that these are a professional third rail
at the very least right also illegal
therefore if I talk about them am I
giving someone probable cause am I going
to get myself in some type of really
tricky legal situation Etc there are a
lot of considerations but
I tested that just like I was saying I
like to capture my assumptions on paper
so I can stress test and I was like okay
I think that might be true most people I
know think that is true but is it true
how could we test to see if that is true
or not and I decided to crowdfund for
a Hopkins pilot study looking at
psilocybin for treatment resistant
depression and I thought to myself okay
we have we have a couple of
a couple of things falling in our favor
here number one depression does not
discriminate so across socioeconomic
classes across gender across race this
is a problem
almost everyone knows someone who takes
antidepressants who is still depressed
okay
treatment resistant depression therefore
is the indication psilocybin is the
intervention
let me crowdfund and I did that
throughout the time crowdrise which was
co-founded by Edward Norton who had
become a friend and was the actor who's
very smart very very very smart also one
of the best investors I've ever met
which a lot of people don't know very
bright guy
so crowdfunded and I also like to put my
money where my mouth is I said okay guys
I'm gonna see this like I'm putting in X
the goal is to raise I think it was
eighty thousand something like that for
the following study and then I was like
let's see let's see what happens and
there was
basically zero negative
blowback and not only once was there no
discernible negative blowback a number
of people and this was deliberate I
wanted to see this a number of people
came out of the woodwork to support in a
bigger way and I was like oh okay I see
you a bunch a handful of folks I knew
and I was like oh interesting okay there
are at least a half a dozen folks who
are studying the same thing or paying
attention to the same thing and then I
just got Bolder I was like okay if I
tested that
let me push
and then let's see what happens and I'll
wait and lo and behold
I realized that the perception did not
match the reality the reality was if
you're talking about indications that
cause an incredible amount of suffering
for a very large number of people
even those who are anti-drug per se just
say no to drugs want Solutions and the
current treatments for many of these
things do not work very well and in the
best of cases or often masking symptoms
and not addressing root causes I would
say so at that point I just went whole
hog and I said okay look I like to think
that I am exactly what you see is what
you get right the person you talk to off
camera the person you talk to on camera
same and if I start feeling like I have
too much to protect I want to do
something to counteract that in other
words if if
if I feel like I need to censor my true
feelings and beliefs maybe not share my
hardships perhaps not
promote certain things because I have a
reputation to lose that's a fragile
position
I want to be as anti-fragile as possible
and so by talking about this I viewed it
as a way of inoculating myself against
fear of reputation loss like okay let me
push this like I'll ride this horse
other people might not but I wanted to
remove the stigma for funding purposes
hopefully open up federal funding that's
starting to happen now from different
agencies
and then to focus on access and
reduction of cost and insurance
reimbursement and so on so I set a game
plan let's call it maybe five years ago
and I've just been slowly methodically
executing on that since and uh the
reason I chose this to focus on and I've
funded other things but I've really
focused on this mental health
Therapeutics which is not limited to
psychedelics
we can talk about some other things that
I find interesting but psychedelics are
like I said what makes it attractive
very uncrowded
you can do a lot with a small amount of
money unlike saying cancer research can
be very hard like okay you're Deca
billionaire great maybe you can do
something interesting and I'm sure other
people could but if you have twenty
thousand fifty thousand dollars it's
going to be hard to make a dent there
and psychedelics you can actually still
make a difference and very high leverage
in part because
these compounds seem to challenge much
of what we assume to be true about
treating Mental Health
and uh so that's uh that makes for an
attractive bet so that's where I've been
been going yeah I'm so glad you shared
that with us and that you did that
exploration
um and that you've been spearheading the
funding efforts uh you know
this podcast has a uh a premium channel
that's for raising funds for scientific
studies we are in the process now making
our first four uh contributions one of
those includes uh work in Nolan Williams
laboratory at Stanford combining
transcranial magnetic stimulation with
um studies of ibogaine and uh 5meo DMT
maybe a few other things but basically
he's free to do what he wants with the
funds we trust him to do great work but
that again was inspired by you right a
podcast with a scientific um slant
certainly
um this podcast obviously has a
scientific slant but the idea of doing
philanthropy for the sorts of work that
really deserves funding and exploration
and um by the way
um in thinking about other hybrid things
that would be fun to do I mean I would
love to uh contribute and join those
efforts because the work to continue to
raise funding for psychedelic studies
and all these great Laboratories
continues right it continues yes and
you've rallied a collection of
um some pretty uh powerful people to
contribute to this and I know you've
joined arms with Michael Pollan in many
ways do you want to talk about the
fellowships that you guys put together I
find that really cool you've got
fellowships uh in the works or maybe
already happening at UC Berkeley is that
right UC Berkeley yeah so the what what
I try to do and for people who want to
check it out it's it's the name of the
foundation is sisei foundation and let
me explain that for a second so it's
s-a-i-s-e-i so SCI savefoundation.org I
speak Japanese I want there's an
exchange student and speak read write it
still to this day pretty well sightsee
can mean a lot of things it means
rebirth in Japanese and I've seen what
can only be described or can certainly
be described as rebirth in so many
clinical outcomes
that I thought it was appropriate to use
and
what I've tried to do with the
foundation is
I think do what I'm pretty good at which
is trying to peek around corners and
find something to prototype right so
just like the CGM and like all right how
can I just getting hold of a Dexcom back
then when it was just for type 1
diabetics was was hard it was something
that you have to actually go under the
skin so it's it's like taking a barbecue
prong and putting it under your
abdominal skin it was not comfortable
can you describe your
um cortisol level and uh subjective
terms when you're at home you got this
thing and you're about to implant it and
you don't have any precedent it's not
like this is you know like levels or one
of these other uh cgms that are out
there United stamp the thing in you can
look on Instagram and see someone else
do it there's nothing like that so
you're at home wondering if you're going
to secure your liver yeah I'm I'm at
home doing it myself and I'm sweating
like a stuck pig I'm sitting there I'm
like oh my God I don't even know if I
can is your girlfriend there like to
support you in case you yeah I think at
the time she wasn't because she was
squeamish and didn't want to see it and
I'm so I'm sitting there at my kitchen
table I remember this God I'm sweating
just thinking about it and
no videos to watch and uh wasn't really
supposed to have it in the first place
and uh the device for readout by the way
no iPhone right right so it's like this
janky
pager looking thing that had a readout
that made you think you were playing
pong or something and it was very the
green the green tint screen yeah
font is so primitive
and uh
put this thing under my skin would tape
I would cut a Ziploc bag and put it on
top and and masking tape it to my skin
to take showers because otherwise it
wouldn't work
and it was it was great and I'll just
say that I don't use Associated you
realize you said it was great I did I
did say it was great because gay wedding
and it was I was afraid but it gave me a
lot of insight okay and then once I had
The Insider work a course of a handful
of weeks then I felt like I didn't
really need it anymore and that was also
just uh
heavy tax to pay you don't have to wear
that thing around look like you have a
you know what is it called a colostomy
bag or something it's just like it was
big it was bulky so
just like I did that
I wanted to do a proof of concept right
the goal was can I use this for a
healthy normal applications will the
insights be actionable
and they were lo and behold similarly
with the foundation since I'm dealing
with smaller amounts of money and I'm
not uh in the billionaire club by any
stretch of the imagination
and science can be expensive I'm looking
for small bets where can I pilot
something that if successful will be
emulated or can be scaled
and so on the say the crowdfunding for
for the Hopkins treatment resistant
depression pilot study we ended up
exceeding the goal they were able to
recruit more subjects in the case of UC
Berkeley Michael pollen and I partnered
on this and my Foundation funded it the
ferris UC Berkeley journalism Fellowship
psychedelic journalism Fellowship is
providing funding to up and coming
journalists
who want to focus on psychedelics as
their beat which to this date has not
been financially feasible
you just don't have the space to do
really long-form investigators and
investigative work
uh the Hope being that these journalists
can apply their skills and their
dedication to examining different facets
of the Psychedelic ecosystem therapeutic
potential uh regulatory issues ETC in a
way that can
shape and inform National and
international discourse in a very
critical way because these things are
not a Panacea there's a lot of claims
that are made about these that are
totally unbacked by any type of Science
and there are a lot of charlatans and so
I want wanted to also invite really
competent really good journalists to the
table who might want to watch for Bad
actors I think that's really important
and so this Fellowship has been been uh
has been awarding fellows with these
grants and I think it's a relatively
small amount of money it's like ten
thousand dollars per something like that
but the outcomes have been amazing we
had a huge I want to say it was 7 000
word piece that was one of the main
features in Rolling Stone magazine huge
piece in National Geographic focused on
iboga and fair trade and some of the
implications for
uh local harvesting and or over
harvesting all the Dynamics present in
that which I think has some incredible
promise for particular forms of uh
opioid use opioid use disorder in
particular but
uh that has been a huge success so the
hope is that other journalism schools
will say that's a great idea and I will
have de-risked it for some other
philanthropist or Foundation or
government say director and agency to
say okay well green like that right
because I've done it and it's been
received very well and it's had a real
impact on how things are moving along
another one would be say at Harvard
Poplar this is at Harvard Law School it
was the first is the first dedicated
team focused on law policy and
regulation related psychedelics from a
legal perspective super important super
important super super important also
another pilot let's just call it uh
proof of concept that Sisley Foundation
funded was
helping to develop curricula for I think
it was Yale Johns Hopkins and NYU
effectively a an accreditation or module
they could put into their existing
Psychiatry MD uh
programs such that people could develop
the skills necessary and the
understanding necessary to administer
psychedelic therapies if and when they
become legal prescribable which if I
understand correctly it
sounds like within the next 12 to 24
months
MDMA assisted Psychotherapy for the
treatment of trauma is likely to become
legal in the hands of
psychiatrists at least it may be certain
clinical psychologists as well in the
U.S is that right through the through
the efforts of the maps group yeah
through through the efforts of maps.org
and we're Dublin many others
that is the tip of the spear so I think
anyone who's interested in psychedelics
should have a vested interest in
supporting those efforts
not because we know everything works I
want to be clear
not because we know our priori that all
these things do all the things no but if
if MDMA fails
it's going to be very hard to draft
it'll be impossible to draft on that
with
commands that are more difficult to
administer like psilocybin which would
be next in line for alcohol use disorder
also major depressive disorder so I I
really feel that just like everything
I've talked about whether it's
networking
putting together for our body
or trying to change National policy and
say uh
reclassification of these compounds
getting them out of schedule one to some
extent
you want to break it down into its
constituent pieces you want to do an 80
20 analysis figure out what the critical
few are and then put them in a logical
sequence and execute the plan
one of the greatest weaknesses in the
Psychedelic ecosystem is there are a lot
of people who just want to do all the
things and save all the people and all
the animals and all the places all at
once and that just doesn't work very
well there are also some really good
people who are executing and we could
talk about the for-profit side and so on
but I've been very very very pleased
with the outcomes that scissor
Foundation has been able to achieve with
very limited money I'm prouder of those
outcomes than I am of the startup record
and the startup record is pretty good
and it's the same lens I'm using the
same
the same filters and the same approach
uh which is kind of what I'm always
looking for I'm looking for stuff
that'll translate across Fields if
possible and then you mentioned one like
TMS I think TMS very interesting
transcranial magnetic stimulation yeah
which at one point was
um more commonly used to inhibit
specific brain areas this is a
non-invasive technique uh I've had it
done whereas over my motor cortex and
you're tapping your finger and all of a
sudden you can't tap your fingers it's
pretty eerie but now it can be used to
stimulate at particular frequencies
enhance neuroplasticity and and in
combination with psychedelics is the
it's kind of the burning question now
can you get a a synergistic effect of
TMS and and uh psychedelics maybe
um not just during the the psilocybin or
Ebola Journey but in the days and weeks
after when we know for sure a lot of
plasticity is still occurring so keep
the plasticity on board or accelerate it
yeah so TMS uh also is a monotherapy
very interesting to me for depression
anxiety even substance use disorders
super interesting and there are many
different protocols all sorts of
different technology uh I would say low
intensity or low power ultrasound also
super interesting uh for various various
applications potentially to addiction so
I'm not to be clear a
card carrying
evangelist for psychedelics I am a
proponent of looking for high leverage
on crowded Bets with limited downside
and testing them out and
very optimistic about psychedelics
if anyone listening has a family history
of say schizophrenia borderline
personality disorder which we might
which this is being very simplistic but
categorize or describe as more chaotic
conditions compared to hyper-rigid
conditions like an OCD or anorexia
nervosa
uh chronic depression Etc then we can
talk about why some of these
psychedelics at least some of the
classical psychedelics seem to have
cross efficacy with multiple conditions
but
psychedelic seemed very helpful for
certain types of hyper rigidity when you
get into in schizophrenia and borderline
personality disorder they can be really
heavily contraindicated not to say they
cause those con those conditions but
they can precipitate the onset of those
symptoms and for that reason can be very
destabilizing and dangerous for for
certain people
however that's where something like
metabolic Psychiatry comes in and the
use of ketosis in the ketogenic diet
which appears to be
very effective in some patients for that
grouping of say more chaotic conditions
which is very exciting so I'm interested
in in any tools that are off the beaten
path that seem to raise interesting
questions that have not been answered in
a satisfying way yet in medicine
and I think we're still largely in the
Dark Ages with respect to Psychiatry oh
I think the best psychiatrists would
agree with you yeah and and the best
psychiatrists uh
and the best scientists
and the best fill in the blank are
acutely aware of the limitations of our
current methods and the limitations of
our current knowledge so I think the
mark of a good thinker the mark of a
good scientist the mark of a good fill
in the blank anything is someone who
says I'd have no idea or we have no idea
a lot and hopefully they also say let's
go figure it out or try to try some
things and I I really want to thank you
for sharing that narrative especially
because it makes clear that you brought
the same systematic process of using and
asking excellent questions to arrive at
solutions to arrive at more questions to
fund areas of inquiry and to do it all
in this really structured way as you
said from policy all the way down to
like how many grams or uh you know X of
of some substance somebody might take I
mean I think Matthew Johnson's
laboratory at Hopkins uh Roland
Griffiths uh Robin cardard Harris at
UCSF Nolan Williams the maps group Rick
Dublin Peter Hendrix at University of
Alabama looking under cocaine addiction
yeah other things yeah you Michael
pollen um you know I'm leaving some
names out here and I don't want to take
anything away from the um classic uh as
they're called explorers of psychedelics
and and writers about psychedelics but
we are in the moment of a Renaissance
now and it's important that this have a
lot of fuel so we'll put a link to
um your philanthropy efforts and and the
journalism uh fellowships as well
because I think there there's going to
be a lot of interest there in a huge
supporter of what you're doing as as you
know and I just think it's the way great
science and clinical progress is made so
yeah
um thanks Andrew yeah it's I uh which
brings me to another parallel topic you
know it used to be that meditation and
psychedelics where you have nested in
the same territory this would be in the
late 60s early 70s the birth of places
like esselen Etc
or the consequence of the Dual
exploration of those things meditation
sort of escaped from the psychedelics
umbrella and vice versa
um starting sometime in the mid-2000s
when neuroimaging became a little bit
more accessible and you know I think
nowadays if you told anybody okay
um you know meditation is good for you
can help uh ratchet down your anxiety
give more self-awareness
um you know improve sleep and on and on
maybe even give some insight into
Consciousness no one's going to bulk
there's a lot of studies there's
thousands of studies my laboratory's
done a few of them there are other
Laboratories who have done uh far more
the book altered traits is the one that
comes to mind the group out of Wisconsin
it was early to early to the game on
this
um in any event you talked about TM
um I'm curious from a practical
standpoint do you still meditate daily
do you do meditation Retreats
um what sorts of meditative practices do
you have because I realize this can be
done walking writing is some form of
meditation what sorts of formal
practices do you still engage in now
yeah I do 10 to 20 minutes in the
morning
so I am not currently doing the TM twice
daily 20 minutes I think that would be
better for me probably do you set a
clock and you or yeah I'll set a clock
uh which would be more of the
concentration practice of say a TM where
you're repeating a mantra honestly it
could be any
in my opinion some TM purists will balk
at this but uh it could be really any
nonsense syllable could be a word
although I think something without any
attached meaning is probably more
beneficial for a host of reasons so it
could be a concentration practice with
20 minutes of sitting
it might also be a guided meditation and
I have no vested interest in this app
but I think the waking up app by Sam
Harris is fantastic
I have used the introductory course
which is Sam leading you through my
catnip which is a logical progression of
skill development from day one two three
and and forward I have gone through that
course multiple times when I'm getting
back on the horse for meditation as a
bit of a reboot once you develop I think
a certain degree of awareness and
mindfulness I do think there are other
activities that probably
allow you the parallel experience of
doing one thing while experiencing some
of the benefits of meditation
and so for me I wonder at times are the
benefits of meditation the concentration
practice itself is it just sitting still
with my eyes closed closed down
regulating my system a little bit
activating my parasympathetic and not
rushing or doing anything for 20 minutes
is that it maybe
is it
simply correcting my posture for 20
minutes
how do I weight these different inputs
and the the short answer is you probably
don't need to know but I have found that
spending time in silence in nature
without anything to do disallowing
myself from doing things no note-taking
no reading Etc and spending I I have
spent a number of extended fasts in
nature just like water only by myself no
talking no reading no writing what's
extended seven days generally wow so
you're camping in nature with just water
yep that's it by myself
and there are risks associated with that
right you got to be careful not stupid
about it but
that does a lot for me with some
persistent benefits are there some
favorite places that you've gone into
nature it doesn't have to be too fast
like for instance I'm a big fan of
um some of the national parks up in the
Pacific Northwest because it's like
being transported to a different planet
Yosemite is obviously amazing but any
favorite spots
um where we won't go people won't go
looking for you there don't worry yeah
you live in Austin all the time so
that's right yeah yeah so I would say
uh Colorado Utah New Mexico spending
time in mountains around rivers lakes I
find
very therapeutic
and just gorgeous I I do think we suffer
from uh
awe deficiency disorder you know a bit
of add when we're
trapped in the mundane and for too long
with too much distraction with too many
to Do's with too many relationships
and there's no space for other
there isn't the room necessary all isn't
from my perspective generally a quick
hit that you get in the 30 seconds
between using two apps
there's there's more Breathing Room
required for genuine transcended
experience of awe so I try to on a
yearly basis
as one of my top priorities block out
these weeks of time in nature yeah last
year was the first year I did that I
went out to Colorado
um in August and just took daily hikes I
stayed in a hotel I'm not as beasty as
you do we need to water fast I was
eating every day but
um it was spectacular one thing I
noticed and I'd like to know your
process on
how do you handle going back into life
um great question you know because those
days were and are amazing right you know
like detached and you know maybe one
text message here or there in between
hikes or something and then you just
really clued in even the the process of
watching a show at night like one felt
so rich and like enough so I wasn't um
as aesthetic as you or and uh like
really cleaned all the Clutter but once
you return to life it's almost like
being a wash and demands and and I can
see from a place of more Equanimity how
one could make better choices but how do
you handle those transitions the
re-entry yeah so before getting to the
re-entry I think it might make sense for
me to talk about what comes before so
let's say it's like
pre during post
part of the reason I do these one week
or longer periods Off the Grid is
because it forces me to put better
systems in place
so there's the benefit that you derive
from say that week and I have three
weeks coming up right after this
interview where I'm going to be off the
grid
to set myself up for three weeks off the
grid I have a team I have the podcast I
have a lot of things that are in motion
at any given point in time
if you disappear for say a two to four
week period generally you cannot let the
whole house catch on fire then come back
and put it out effectively which means
you need to put some policies and rules
and so on in place in advance
and there's a carryover effect that has
a host of benefits and makes things
smoother for the re-entry so they're
related like the more you set up the pre
the easier the post is going to be and
then you have this beautiful expansive
experience in nature whatever it might
be whether you're making it a supper
Fest like I do or at a hotel at night
either way these things can work and
nature in and of itself is super helpful
I do think that a lot of the time we
like to imagine because we're driven
smart accomplished people that our
problems are very complex and at the end
of the day it's like you just need some
time in nature and a cold shower and
some macadamia nuts and you'll
be fine you don't need to solve like all
the existential dilemmas of humankind
actually or fancy Pharmaceuticals so
you have this experience over this week
and what I will do then is
set at least a
let's call it integration period of two
to three days where I will slowly Edge
back in
to my previous routine I will not within
12 hours of getting back to so-called
civilization have a day full of calls or
meetings I will not do that it's too
much of a shock to the system and I
think it robs you of a tail end of
benefits
which would also be the case with say
faster ketogenic diet or any number of
interventions you can squeeze out a long
tail of benefits if you make a handful
of changes for instance after an
extended fast what if you started with a
sub caloric ketogenic diet for a few
days you get to extend some of the
benefits as opposed to going straight
back to say a diet that includes a lot
of carbohydrates similarly when you
create more of a vacuum more space for
awe Insight reflection recovery
I think you're doing yourself a
disservice if you jump from park into
sixth gear and so I plan for that and
it's a function of scheduling
I also have a predictable weekly
schedule so I tend to schedule podcast
recordings on Mondays and Fridays in
preparation for an extended trip I will
batch a lot of similar activities that
we have say a bunch of episodes in the
bank that are pre-scheduled everything
is figured out in advance
and over time the more you take these
breaks the better your systems become
and the more liberated you are from the
day-to-day which means when you get back
you also don't need to rush as much into
hyperactivity and if you do you know
that that is more from a compulsivity
than from a necessity
while you're on these nature Retreats
are you writing on a daily basis are you
just thinking and allowing thoughts to
enter and leave your system
depends on the retreat so sometimes I'm
writing
but writing I think can underscore for
me a desire to be compulsively
productive
and I think that is inversely correlated
to my happiness or sense of well-being a
lot of the time
so there are many areas in my life now
so if you were to ask me what has
changed significantly since the time
that you wrote before our body I would
say that
rather than looking for areas to
optimize I am looking where I can very
deliberately de-optimize certain areas
to increase sense of well-being where
can I de-optimize where can I stop
measuring Where can I
stop reading books which areas
can I ignore completely what types of
information can I just excise from my
life all together for a period of time
delete Twitter
stop reading about books in X related to
say AI
or whatever it might be like where can I
de-optimize selectively to sort of
optimize the whole does that make sense
makes good sense yeah and before we
started recording I gave you a book
which is a short collection of poetry
by uh halaliza gafori which is called
gold this collection of roomy poetry
reading poetry is an activity almost by
definition which is
is the antithesis of optimization
so I've tried to also integrate more of
those activities into my life and this
relates to your question because there
are times when I will force myself to
sit on my goddamn hands and not write
not read just do the thing that is so
uncomfortable sometimes which is just
sitting there with yourself
you know it can be incredibly
uncomfortable I am in part because of
the fear that it could become
comfortable yeah right especially for
proactive people with a strong to use
Paul Conti's words generative drive you
know you're gonna
that's uh you know the which is a good
thing uh yeah I believe it's a good
thing and it it can be a good thing it
can indicate
really incredible
adaptations it can also sometimes I
think indicate maladaptations
right and so I think it's it's helpful
to take a break from that generative
drive or at least just
put it in park position
to see if that generative Drive is
is perhaps indicative of you leaning
towards something in a healthy proactive
way versus running from something in a
long-term destructive way yeah well and
I think Paul would say that part of the
generative Drive process is peace you
know not as necessarily even as a still
state but as a um you know being able to
experience peace even in the Transitions
and there's a lot more to say about that
and he would say it far better than I
ever would so I'll uh leave it at that
and um I mean for people who have the
option
getting in nature it doesn't have to be
all day every day on a water fast I just
take certain things to an extreme
because that's who I am but sorry when
you say water fast that means fasting
with water
right it's just that thing but yes
drinking water it just means you're
allowed to have water and nothing else
for for a long time I thought it meant
that you're not drinking water oh yeah
no don't do that some people do that
right they do these crazy food water
fasts um as a way I think they believe
it clears sent us in cells or something
but
um probably clears a lot more than just
sent us in cells yeah I uh there might
be something to it I mean look there are
people who recycle by drinking their own
urine not my jam uh but I would say it's
like three hours without shelter or
three days without water three weeks of
that food general rule of thumb so be
careful with dehydration you can go a
long time without food if you have I
don't care how ripped you are you get
eight percent body fat man you got
plenty of time you can go a couple weeks
no problem yeah you got calories 9 000
calories per pound store body fat you
got plenty don't worry uh
so for people who have the option to be
in nature and just exercise several
hours a day
to exhaustion
see how many of your problems seem to
just go away
let's try that yeah well my Sunday
routine is to try and get outside and
move as much as possible yeah I don't
always succeed but
um I'm going to try a longer retreat
into nature I think um
Olympic National Forest is is calling me
again it seems like once a year I just
want to get back up there it's uh it's
Colin you should get back out there it's
spectacular I have a question about
mentors I'm a big believer in mentors
either mentors that know us and we know
them or people that we assign as mentors
without them realizing it
um this sort of thing uh do you have
mentors at this stage of life
um for particular areas of life where
you you mentoring yourself are you
flying with a few voices in your head uh
that serve you well who are your mentors
I definitely have people I consider
mentors it's I think at this point
rarely one way in the sense that they
tend to be friends
I spend time with they get something
from it I get something from it not in a
transactional way but they find it fun
or beneficial or amusing
in some way redeeming to spend time with
me that's the hope but how is that
different from like traditional
friendship you know to sort of standard
friendship are you focus are you
spending time with some orientation
toward like their embodying areas of
life that you would like to emulate
totally I mean I spend I spend time
around people
I hope to be more like in some way
because guess what you're going to
average
into say the the just the some holistic
whole of the five or six people you
spend the most time with so you should
choose that very carefully that includes
virtual parasocial relationships okay if
you're listening to fill in the blank
person
for four hours a week five hours a week
two hours a week whoever that group
is comprised of is going to influence
who you become and
for me then I think carefully about my
friendships and they could be older like
Kevin Kelly has become a good friend
who has a wealth of life experience that
I don't have and so I might just call
him and say Kevin I have a question for
you but I do that with my younger
friends too and they could be younger
than I am and I might still view them as
a mentor in X Y or Z I think Mentor has
a
heavy weight to it it has a connotation
of
maybe never ending time-consuming
obligation so I I would never for
instance I know a lot of people try this
ask someone to be my mentor it's like
would you like to be my free life coach
forever you know I was like that's kind
of how it sounds to the recipient so it
sounds very formal yeah it sounds very
formal yeah it's so for me I would say
there have certainly been mentors I've
had wrestling coaches I've had teachers
I've had resident advisors who are
reverence who had a huge impact on my
life and followed up with me and paid
attention to me and cared for me in more
of a one directional
sense right I I view myself as the
beneficiary of course they they
certainly got something out of it if
they had that job and they probably
found it to be very gratifying in its
own way
and teachers like Professor Ed Shao at
Princeton I feel in incredibly indebted
to
these days
and for a long time I've believed that
you can learn something
powerful from almost anyone probably
anyone you interact with
could be an Uber driver could be someone
taking garbage out of a restaurant if
you really take the time to dig you can
find something and
before you can I think as an adult
effectively think about who you would
like to learn from if I put it that way
it's helpful to have a baseline of
self-awareness that you know what you
might want to work on to either amplify
strengths develop skills address
weaknesses and so for instance one of my
close friends Matt mullenweg is younger
than I am
he's the he's the founder of automatic
which runs wordpress.com he is the lead
developer of Wordpress although it was
an open source project of course with
many many contributors he was one of the
lead developers Now power something like
32 of the internet and he exemplifies a
cool and calm temperament even in the
most chaotic periods imaginable during
the most chaotic events imaginable and
when I find myself getting
dysregulated he's a fancy term losing my
or getting carried away by emotion
getting righteously angry or whatever it
might be and I recognize at some point
that it's really not serving me and that
I am being owned by the emotion right
like I'm the dog on the leash not the
other way around
then I think of that I'm like what would
Matt do
what advice would Matt give me right now
how would Matt act in these
circumstances and
I do that with with many friends I also
think a lot about and this is borrowing
from someone named Kathy Sierra
from a long time ago focusing more on
just-in-time information as opposed to
just in case information so just in case
information is like I'm going to read
these 20 books because in two years I
might be interested in
x y and z
that I think is often a waste of time
because if it ever becomes relevant
you're just gonna have to reread those
books
people do the same thing with humans
they're like I want to meet so and so
and have them as my mentor because maybe
five years from now I'll do X Y and Z
and then they'll be useful for ABC
that's too speculative and I think it
ends up in a lot of wasted energy so
the podcast for me
writing the books and doing the
interviews
even prior to the podcast becoming
involved with startups
delving into the world of science and
scientists
all helped me to
develop a confidence that
almost any question I could ask
I can find some semblance of an answer
for by just reaching out to a few people
and saying who do you know who might be
able to answer this
and that's very reassuring and it
relieves some of the anxiety or pressure
that people might feel to assemble some
personal board of directors of like
X-Men and women who can help them with
everything
and then there are people I hire to be
accountable to right so I might work
with coaches therapists
and so on who I would view as mentors
they just happen to get getting paid for
it right yeah the reason I asked the
question is because we were talking
about the meditative process going into
nature and even with psychedelics
there's you know they can be viewed a
lot of different ways but I think of
them largely as going inward to explore
I mean you're out in nature and learning
from nature
um there's such a court truth to Nature
I know that sounds a little bit you know
uh
wishy-washy but it's uh it's true like
if it's there it's concrete it's really
something uh it was there long before
any of us and it'll be there a lot
longer than any of us uh will ever be we
hope
um uh certainly if it goes we go
um but the process of learning from
others and paying attention to others is
really an outward looking thing I mean
we have to bring that in but I was just
curious how you balance those and as a
way to really understand not just your
time allocation right I think we could
talk about that you know what's how's
your morning structured Etc which I
think there's Great Value in in knowing
but more
um what what's your mind allocation
right I think about this you know like
where's my brain is it am I focused on
what's going on in here and you know is
that is there a need to excavate there
sure you know about how much time am I
out of my head and bringing things in
from the outside world and back and
forth so do you have some sense of
um across the year
across the day how you mind allocate I
don't know if um that's the best phrase
but I can't think of any better one if
you can think of a better one please
please uh table it because I'm happy to
use that how do I think about mind
allocation or attention allocation
I try to
and most frequently think of my mind
share
across a year
and across
week
a weekly time frame and
I find that to be manageable in the
sense that on a yearly basis
on New Year's Eve or roughly around New
Year's every year I'll do a past year
review pyr past year review where I'll
go back and I'll look at my entire last
year
a piece of paper in front of me lying
down the center
plus negative and I will go through
every week in my calendar for the
previous year and I will write down the
people places activities commitments Etc
that produced Peak positive emotional
experiences
so all right we're doing an 80 20
analysis here like what are the big
rocks that really move the needle in a
meaningful way and conversely who are
the people what are the things what are
the places that just made me go
and were draining produced Peak negative
experiences why the hell did I commit to
this type experiences
and that presents me with a do more of
do less of list then I look forward to
the next year and I did this
I suppose just a handful of months ago
around New Year's
with the Positive I'm like okay here's
my list of do more of it's not real
until it's in the calendar let's get
these things in the calendar and then I
will start talking to people booking
things
having people help with organizing if
that is required and getting things
blocked out so I have already
this year and we're in the reasonable
beginning stages of the year I have
things blocked out until November of
this year
and those provide the breaks in the
action
not just the breaks in the action but
the fun stuff because by the way guys
I thought for a long time like yeah I
take care of a b and c and the good
stuff just takes care of itself I've
I do not any longer believe that to be
true unless you schedule these things
that you claim are important they're
gonna get crowded out by
and maybe not but just less
important things
they're urgent will crush the important
so I get these things on the calendar
and then I back up and I look at optimal
weekly
mind allocation right attentional
allocation
and there's a there's there's an
Incredible cost to cognitive switching
if you're just task switching all day so
I will try my best to format a weekly
Rhythm a weekly sequence that allows me
to focus on certain types of tasks
so Mondays very frequently admin of some
type just bits and ends flots and Jetsam
all the miscellaneous pieces that are
part of life you got to deal with them
yeah that tends to be Monday
whenever possible and especially if I'm
focused on physical activity let's just
say I'm in a place like Colorado I will
try to schedule most of that for after
lunch
to ensure that I get in a lot of
exercise and movement in the first
portion of the day not everybody has
that ability but I will say more of you
have that capacity than you might think
because most of what we all do is just
not important
time on social media first thing in the
morning is probably the most poisonous
activity that I could take part in I I
don't want to you know point fingers at
anyone else but oh yeah I think if
people ask you know what what is the you
know amount of time it takes to get in a
really good workout
it's going to be about an hour you know
but a lot can be done in 45 if we're
even 30 minutes let me think about how
quickly that time goes by yeah I'm sure
I'm not the only one uh that is part of
the reason I deleted a lot of these apps
from my phone it's like I would be I'd
go into the bathroom to take a you know
quick bit of business and then 45
minutes later I'm like how have I been
looking at Instagram for 45 minutes yeah
lines in for restrooms have gotten very
long in the last 10 10 years has anyone
noticed that the weight for the
restrooms has gotten yeah so yeah you
have time for the important stuff I
think and just look at some of the
extreme overachievers out there they
have the same amount of time that you do
have you I was going to ask this later
I'll just we'll just quickly interject
this now
um have I saw perhaps it was on Twitter
maybe I overheard this that you're back
on Instagram it's uh I mean you've
always had an account yeah that posts
but are you back in there are you out of
there
um I mean like my the Dirty Little
Secret I'm single again and that's a
great way to connect with with eligible
ladies who might be of interest
so you're on um so you're on Instagram
I'm willing to pay the tax of dealing
with the brain damage of using Instagram
as a result hey look finding a great
life partner is exactly it's great
exactly so that's that is the reason for
that but
otherwise it would not be on my phone
it's too it wouldn't even be on your
phone absolutely not it's too well
designed these companies are very smart
they have very good data scientists they
have very good UI specialists
if anyone out there thinks that they can
like maybe maybe Jocko can can
discipline his way through it I'm sure
he can because he's he is Jocko but in
my case in the case of most people like
you're bringing a knife to a gunfight if
you think you can use your self-control
to keep your use of Instagram to say 10
minutes at a club good luck yeah and
even if you can
people say ah but I do that anyway I'm
like all right how much time do you
spend sending memes and links from
Instagram or fill in the blank platform
to your friends and group chat how much
time is that consume I spend a fair
amount of time on Instagram and Twitter
posting things related to the podcast
but
um I don't have someone to do that for
me and I I actually enjoy doing it and
it challenges me in certain ways but I
completely agree with everything you're
saying I also want to note that you
didn't say that you're on Twitter uh
possibly to meet somebody
um which is more a statement about
Twitter yeah yeah it's not that it's not
the not the friendliest neighborhood
I've found and uh I would say Twitter
has its use cases I I find it useful in
some respects it has become much less
useful and much less practical in the
last year with a lot of the product
changes but
it has its place it's not on my phone it
was on my phone for a very brief period
of time
I do not want
I find that my ability to be still in
calm
is eroded
if I am
too easily able to escape boredom
if you cease to have the ability to be
bored for five to ten minutes I think
that makes you very fragile and makes
you very easy to manipulate also
and there are a lot of forces at play
online that want to manipulate or shape
your behavior in different ways so I
feel like it is imperative for me to
cultivate the ability to just sit still
and not consume the five minutes in line
waiting to get into a restaurant by
hopping on Twitter or Instagram
so that's part of the reason they're not
on my phone could you tell us about
punch
yeah I can tell you about punch so
is a creative project
intended once again to make me less
precious about protecting whatever brand
I think I might have
and this is an investment in my
long-term mental health also and I think
in my career flexibility my willingness
to experiment
punch could be a long story but the
gist of it is I wanted to experiment
with fiction writing I've been saying
this for years and I've never done it
that's the backdrop
on top of that I have wanted to get back
into illustration and work in the visual
arts which I did for a long time when I
was younger
and I've not done that consistently
why not because I haven't had
accountability I haven't had deadlines
it hasn't been in the calendar this
should sound somewhat familiar by now
and at the same time I was becoming very
interested in web3 and what was
happening in the world of nfts this is
probably 2020 and I know they've
developed a fairly negative connotation
for a lot of good reasons
but I started to think about fundraising
for early stage science and if I could
do
if I could conduct an experiment
as a proof of concept with different
novel approaches to fundraising so
rather than just calling the rich
friends who might sort of Bend to the
pressure
or be willing to fund I wanted to look
at say crowdfunding back in the day then
I wanted to look at different options
for perhaps art auctions and I was going
to do this with with Contemporary Art
this is many years ago and in the
process of wanting to fund the the
Hopkins Center focused on psychedelic
and Consciousness research which which
the was the first of its kind in the
United States
and the technology gave me the
opportunity
to learn about a new
let's just call it set of Technologies
so to develop skills and knowledge it
would give me the opportunity to
reconnect and deepen friendships with a
number of my very very smart friends who
are playing in that area
also test fundraising also get back into
fiction and art and all that combined
into this thing that I ended up calling
punch because it made me laugh and
you know what
man if you take your work too seriously
you're gonna burn out before you get the
really serious work done and I think it
was uh Bertrand Russell has said it's a
sure sign of an impending nervous
breakdown if you start taking your work
too seriously or believing your work to
be very very serious
and
for that reason
I wanted to give it an absurd name that
would also have some Word of Mouth
benefit
and that to
see what would happen honestly just see
what happened because I was like all
right look
what is honestly the worst thing that
happens like people write a bunch of
pieces where they're like shaking their
fist at the sky how dare to empharis
create a project you could turn it
around on them and just say that what
they were doing is a punch
attempting well that was kind of the
thing uh that was kind of part of the
thinking that it would just be
entertaining to watch people seriously
trying to critique something called
punch and uh the upshot of that is it
raised almost two million dollars sold
out in something like 30 minutes or 40
minutes for the foundation all that
money went to Science Foundation all
that money has already been distributed
in the form of Grants wonderful and uh
along the way I got to work with artists
with programmers learn new technologies
reconnect with old friends and now we're
back in touch and it's it's extremely
fun to be back in touch with these folks
and I've written
the equivalent of a short book in
fiction in the form of short stories
that are this Fantasy World building
exercise for me and I'm having a blast
so I'm exercising new creative muscles
that has led me back into the worlds of
comic books which I haven't created yet
led me back into the worlds of gaming
led me back into my fascination of
tabletop gaming because I played DND
forever when I was a kid that was my
refuge as a runt who got the crap kicked
out of them left and right
and I'm having just a blast and the
the takeaway I think on some level is
that you should do things
should as is a is a is a loaded
term
it's helpful for me to consider doing
things that give me energy right because
if we say all right time management is
fine
but
time doesn't really have any practical
value unless you have attention right so
then there's attentional management but
that attention is limited also
physically and sort of metaphorically by
energy right so you have like substrates
diets neurotransmitters and so on if you
do not have the the basic batteries
required
the rest of the things that are higher
up on Nap pyramid
can't really be executed properly so for
me it's like okay let's say punch
doesn't do anything it's total failure
right coming back to like we're already
raised two million dollars for science
it didn't that science could be break
through science so good it could so
punch sorry yeah sorry so punch is
at least thus far a success it is but
coming back to Seth goodin's question I
asked myself would I do this even if it
turns out to be a complete failure
financially and I was like yes because I
think the relationships and the skills
even if this quote unquote fails from
the outside looking in those will
transcend this project and be
life-affirming and helpful and fun in
other areas and that's proven to be true
even though the project is ongoing
and
I have more energy now because of this
ridiculous project I'm very proud of the
fiction actually this ridiculous project
called punch people can find the
legend of cockpunch on uh any fine
provider of podcasts and hired voice
actors did the scripting the production
I hit number one fiction worldwide on
Apple podcast for a while the whole
thing's hilarious and um and if you
could can you explain a little bit about
the characters in punch yeah who's
who's punching who's yeah yeah or
which are punching yeah which
are punching which how does this
work so
here we go all right so the legend of
punch
takes place in this realm called varlata
and verlata is being described through
the narrator
who we know as the seventh scribe we
don't know much about the seventh scribe
but sevenscribe makes an appearance in
episode one as the reliable but possibly
sometimes unreliable narrator of this
space and there's a there's a
mind-bending Time component where
there's something called restarts
something like the edge of tomorrow if
people have ever seen this movie where
time restarts maybe like Groundhog Day
time restarts and it's unclear as of yet
in the story why that is the case but
people basically snap into being they
know who they are and what they do but
they have no real memories to speak of
so the world is constantly being
reconstructed and pieced together by
these scribes the seventh of which is
the narrator so you can you you might
read into this that I am a fan of
fantasy Tolkien you name it Ursula Kate
Le Guin uh the wizard of earthy Etc
then there are eight primary
houses these are the greater houses some
might call them Clans and they have
different characteristics
just prior to this seven scribe
beginning his piecing together which
turns into the story in the podcast
there was a Warring States period this
much he's been able to establish
and the peacekeeping mechanism that was
devised is something called the great
games and the great games is a combat
competition
and
the eight greater houses send their best
fighters who've been vetted through
preliminary competitions to the great
games which is in the free trade zone
which is this one place where all of the
races mingle and trade and so on
and all these characters happen to be
anthropomorphized roosters so
they have uh generally each one Gauntlet
of some type and clearly they punch each
other with this Gauntlet and there are
many other types of weapons so the
colloquial nickname for this Olympics of
combat
is punch and that is the that is
the etymology
so the scholars say of Punch The
Legend Of punch and there's a lot
more to it and there are many wrinkles a
lot of Easter eggs in this entire story
the idea came to me and it started off
as a bit of a farce right it was just
going to be something funny
see if it works maybe it raises some
money very light lift
but once I got into the fiction I
started digging it super seriously so
it's become very very elaborate it's
become really really elaborate and I'm
loving it it's great so who knows where
it'll go I have no idea that's part of
the reason why I called it an emergent
long fiction project I didn't call it an
nft project I was like this is an
emergent long fiction project where I'm
taking inputs from the audience I'm I'm
watching very closely what people
understand or don't understand or find
interesting I'm looking at for instance
what is generated when I host an an AI
assisted art competition which I did
with the fans
and a lot of these bits and pieces get
integrated in some fashion into this
thing that chapter by chapter is
coalescing so that's Scott bunch
amazing and I had to buy cockpunch.com
and the ad punch Twitter
you had to buy it from somebody oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah the whole process I
don't want to ask what it was being used
for prior to your purchase it was not
being used for uh Fantasy World building
I'll put it that way got it
amazing and for so many reasons I have
so much to say but first of all your
excitement about it is tangible yeah the
energy you have around it is infectious
um and
well I don't want to go into the total
um depth and Contour of uh what Paul
Conte has been telling me over the last
week of preparing this mental health
series about what's really great in life
that we all should cultivate it has a
lot to do with this generative Drive
which has a lot to do with positive
energy not just positive thinking but
positive energy but this
um this Triad of Peace contentment and
delight and as you were explaining it
it's clear that it brings you great
peace contentment and Delight as action
terms not like sit there and just hover
in the Basking in it it's just so clear
that this is a great idea
um and I love that you started it as a
way to kind of um
uh I don't know like knock the fear out
of yourself a little bit by knocking a
little fear into the whole thing yeah
like like what would happen if you let
your mind go and and allowed yourself
yeah to explore this and and what
permission would it buy you if it's not
a total disaster this is true for the
for our body too I'm like what if this
partially works it's not even a home run
but let's say I get on base what
permission does this then buy me what
other Impossibles and quotation marks am
I willing to challenge
and I was able to make the Hop from one
category in the bookstore to a
completely different category and then
this guy's limit I was like I can do
anything I can do whatever I want I've
given myself permission and the market
has given me permission but the most
important
first step is you giving yourself
permission and with say punch as
ludicrous as it is
now that I've done that my career hasn't
ended hasn't had any negative impact on
my career whatsoever I'm like
okay that's actually kind of surprising
to the contrary it seems like it gives
you energy it raised money for science
is it still raising money it's it's not
is there still an opportunity for people
to No it's it's sold out uh if people
want to contribute to say the early
stage science
and let's just say specifically
psychedelics I would say it's very very
hard to get
a very solid understanding of
the field and the shifting Sands and the
projects and so on it's it's very
rapidly changing so I would say just
provide
money to a foundation that's already
doing good work it could be a river
sticks Foundation it could be Beckley
Foundation my Foundation scissor
Foundation I think does pretty good work
and scissor is not just the the
journalism fellowships there are also
this uh it's funding for psychedelics oh
yes there's tons of stuff there's a
project page on
scissorfoundation.org you can see the
projects they're probably 15 to 20 of
them and they can see the basic science
all the way from really basic science
looking at possible mechanisms of action
for something like dipt which is a very
strange compound that the ipt yeah most
people aren't going to know it that that
produces
profound auditory distortions and
hallucinations in humans very hard to
animal model
and
from that all the way up to really
sophisticated Imaging studies from that
to say at least a year or two ago
supporting phase three trials for MDMA
assisted Psychotherapy then the
journalism then the this then that but a
lot of a lot of different uh scientific
studies that are that are being
supported so that's that's very exciting
to me and but the the punch side of
things is all done Money's been
distributed uh and maybe I'll do more of
this kind of thing but I might take a
different approach I I feel like okay I
learned what I feel
I wanted to learn from that and maybe
I'll try something new next time
one thing's clear nobody tells you what
to do
um except you and but that's vetted
through many important filters like
structured filters and um very
thoughtful filters or the words that
come to mind when I think about your
process as you're sharing one more thing
which is
one of the sources of Joy Of punch
is that it is not over planned I set
some initial conditions and now it's
emergent
and as someone who has hyper analyzed
and meticulously planned most of my life
for decades
I think it's helpful to have an improv
component
so if you are a hyper planner
if you're a hyper measurer if you like
that degree of control maybe you should
try something that's a little less
controlled take an improv class try
fiction writing do something that isn't
totally scripted where you don't know
the outcome I think it's really good
medicine for people just like if you
spend all your time in a yoga class
maybe you should spend one day a week
lifting weights see what that's like and
if you spend all your time in the gym
and you can barely touch your toes maybe
you should do some more downward dog try
some yoga similar I think the spectrum
of hyper planned to completely
free-flowing and Improv
provides ample opportunity to
enrich themselves and maybe address some
weaknesses at the same time so for me
punch has been incredibly
therapeutic probably the first time that
anyone's ever uttered that sentence but
yes probably yeah but that's part of
what makes it so cool yeah totally I
love it
I'm wondering if you'd be willing to
share with us a little bit about
your mindset
um maybe even your motivation but
um certainly your mindset around sharing
some of the hard
personal tribulations that you shared uh
in preparation for this discussion today
I went back to some of those posts that
you did and the
um podcasts that you did around this and
I'd listen to them at the time and
um you know they deal with quite serious
violations of childhood and of self and
um they're hard I mean they're they're
hard to listen to and I can only imagine
they must be even
far far harder to experience and I was
curious what led to your willingness to
do that
and um
yeah I mean I have my own ideas about
what might have motivated it but I'd
like to hear it from you sure happy to
talk about it uh and I think there are
two particular examples that come to
mind
so one is my
near suicide in college and
uh if people search
some practical thoughts on suicide and
my name it'll pop right up I mean if you
just search
my name and suicide it'll probably pop
right up
pretty well indexed at this point which
is very deliberate
people can look at the URL structure for
a little wink and uh hat tip uh I'll
tell you something about optimizing for
Google if you look at it I'll just tell
you the URL is spells out how to commit
suicide but clearly I'm not teaching
people how to commit suicide but I
wanted
that to be a Honeypot for some of that
traffic because it's a lot easier now to
find that type of practical
implementation advice
and it's a bit harder to find I think
compelling intervention
so first of all if you're feeling
suicide obviously call Suicide Hotline
please right that's sometimes the last
thing that people want to hear when they
are in a place of suicidal ideation
and the reason I ended up writing a long
post about this which was terrifying to
write because I had never
told my parents I'd never told my
closest friends this was a secret this
is a dark dark secret
and
I wrote about it because
I went to an event
in San Francisco I was interviewed on
stage by Jason calcanus who's a friend
and a very good interviewer
at an event and after I got off stage
a bunch of people approached me and I
was saying hi and taking photos and
signing things and so on
and there was one young man there very
well dressed
which isn't really relevant I just it
was striking because in San Francisco
sometimes people are very underdressed
and he was he had dressed up for it like
he'd taken it seriously and he was in a
suit and tie and he asked me if I could
sign a book for his brother
and
I said sure no problem and I asked him
what would you like me to write to your
brother and he kind of blanked he didn't
kind of blank he totally blanked but the
look behind his eyes was
unusual it wasn't just I don't know what
to say blank there was something else
behind it and I could tell that he felt
under pressure
and I said no problem take your time
I'll tell you what I'll just chat with a
couple of other people and I'll sign the
book no problem I'm not going anywhere
and chatted with the other folks and
then
he asked if he could just walk me to the
elevator and then I could sign the book
I was like sure
and he explained to me
as I walked to the elevator how his
brother had been a huge fan of mine
and that
I'd really kept his brother afloat for a
long time and eventually his brother
killed himself
and that they'd kept his room exactly
how it was
and he wanted me to sign the book so
that he could put the book in his
brother's room
and
he asked me if I'd ever considered
talking about mental health and mental
health challenges publicly because he
thought it would really help a lot of
people
and that just
I mean I'm like feeling myself tear up
right now I mean it it was so crushing
to hear the story
and totally unbeknownst to him I had a
lot of history
with depressive episodes and when I say
near suicide I had it on the calendar I
had a plan I was going to kill myself I
knew exactly how I was going to do it I
knew where I was going to do it I knew
all of the variables that I needed to
account for to get it done and
the only reason that didn't happen for
people who don't have the contacts which
most people want
is I had tried to reserve a book at
Firestone Library this is at Princeton
which had something to do with suicide
it was like assisted suicide like the
clinician's guide to euthanasia
something like that
and it wasn't in
and I had forgotten to change my address
of the registrar's office I was taking a
year away from school
and that was to focus on finishing my
thesis it was to try a few jobs but I
had ended up in a very bad place
and was feeling very isolated and my
friends were graduating a year ahead of
me and I was stuck on this thesis and
there's a lot of backstory that I won't
bore people with but
got to the point where I decided
not that objectively objectively my life
is bad I think this is where people who
haven't experienced depression get a
little confused or it's hard for them to
identify when they give advice to a
depressed person
because you might say to a depressed
person like but look your life is so
great like there's this there's that
there's this and for a lot of depressed
people to say yeah I know
I look at that and I can't fix my state
because I am broken and if this is how
I'm going to have to live forever
with being this broken and dysfunctional
and to have this internal hell that I
live day by day
I just want to escape it's like someone
jumping out of a burning building it's
like they don't want to kill themselves
but they're jumping out of a burning
building
and
so I had it on the calendar
and thank God this was back when they
would still send you a physical reminder
in the mail a little postcard that says
your book is in and that card went to my
parents house and my mom saw it and
panicked and called me
and I lied I said it was for a friend
who went to Rutgers who was doing a
project on abnc but it's it was just
enough to kind of snap me out of the
trance and realize that
killing yourself is like putting on a
suicide vest with explosives and walking
to a room of all the people you care the
most about and and blowing yourself up
so that snapped me out of it but no one
knew this this guy certainly didn't know
that
and that is when I went home and thought
about it and just decided
okay
there's a chance if I write this it's
not certain but there's a chance this
might help someone it might prevent
someone from doing what I was almost
about to do
and so I spent
months getting this post written and put
it out and I and I know for a fact it
has saved minimum dozens of Lies and
there are other things including a very
extensive list of resources
and uh so that's
gave me
I suppose not a toe in the water but
sort of jumping feet first into the deep
end
an experience of being that vulnerable
and this was a long time ago I mean this
is
I want to say at least eight to ten
years ago when I put that post out and
uh
then uh
I want to say it was just before covid
lockdown
I was in Costa Rica visiting a friend
I was with my girlfriend at the time and
she knew a secret of mine and she was
one of maybe two or three people who
knew
that I'd been sexually abused when I was
a kid by a babysitter's son from two to
four roughly
and
routinely
all the time kind of thing and
like what you're envisioning is is is is
is is what happened so it was not good
and that had been compartmentalized and
locked away for my whole life
I was like that's in the past
we're focused on moving forward
and nothing to be fixed nothing to fix
and that was my my perspective on things
uh
it turned out it wasn't quite that
simple right and
so I had done a lot of work a lot of
therapy used psychedelic therapies as
well
which once again are not all upside
potential there are some significant
risks
but I had come a long way and my plan
had always been to wait until my parents
passed because I didn't want them to
blame themselves for this
and then to write a book and
there was something though at the time
when I was having dinner with my
girlfriend
there was dissatisfying about that plan
if there's something about it that
bothered me and I couldn't quite put a
finger on it and I was talking to her
about it
and she said that's going to take a long
time
she's like have you ever thought about
how many people
are going to
pass away or die
or suffer between now and when you
publish that book
and uh
I thought about it and it was at that
dinner that I decided to at least record
a podcast
covering this terrain I was not at all
convinced that I wanted to publish it I
I was terrified of publishing it also
because it meant opening myself up to a
lot of conversations
or maybe just
uh
hurtful commentary online who knows like
people are there are a lot of idiots out
there and a lot of otherwise fine people
who are idiots on the internet
so it's very hesitant ultimately decided
I I didn't want to do it as a one-man
show I didn't want to make it a
monologue so I asked my friend Debbie
Millman
who had been on my podcast she's an
amazing graphic designer and teacher
but she had unexpectedly on my podcast
based on some of my questions
for the first time publicly told her
story about being sexually abused
and so I had leaned on her in years
after that in private
and I asked her if she would be willing
to have a conversation with me about our
respective Journeys and
what it felt like what it looked like
what helped what didn't help what worked
what didn't to provide at the very least
a glimmer of hope for people who
were keeping some of these dark secrets
or contending with them not knowing what
to do with them and we had that
conversation and I sat on it I sat on it
I sat on it and then I put it out and
decided in advance that I would not look
at any social media for at least several
weeks afterwards
if my team saw anything on social media
got emails I didn't want to see anything
other than positive feedback which is
not my de facto I'm usually
eager to solicit constructive feedback
but in this case I I knew that my own
position was too vulnerable I I didn't
want to
open up the possibility of of
destabilizing myself
and I put it out and
I think it's the most important podcast
I've ever put up so I kind of felt like
my job was done from a podcasting
perspective
after that
and
it's been incredibly gratifying I think
it has certainly helped a fair number of
people and it was also really hard
because what I didn't anticipate was I
would say of my
really super high performing close male
friends
maybe half
reached out to me to tell someone for
the first time about their extremely
awful graphic first-hand experience of
being sexually abused the percentages
were mind-blowing like the the actual
percentages were super super high which
is part of the reason I mentioned
earlier I think it's good to spend a
little bit of time in those empty spaces
to see you know am I
in a positive energetic sense pursuing
something good or am I running away from
demons whipping my back
and
for a lot of those guys I'm sure it's
true for a lot of women too like they
they find medication
through intense focus and achievement
which is super adaptive in a lot of ways
but it doesn't always have
lifetime reliability and
[Music]
that's the story
um it's impossible to hear those stories
your story without feeling some
substantial emotion I'm not trying to
intellectualize it's
um
both both of those aspects of your
history that you shared are huge they
really are they're obviously huge for
you and and they're huge in terms of the
positive impact in the world I I know
this because
um I have read the comments right and I
and I've talked to people who have
listen to those podcasts and read those
blogs and um and have similar or maybe
different stories of trauma but I think
as with your work in the Psychedelic
space as with your work in
um the physical augmentation space
whatever you want to call it
um
it's apparent that you're willing to be
first man in on a lot of things and
really you're sitting alone there in
those moments and uh these categories of
revealing trauma are in my mind anyway
so much more substantial in terms of
their impact positive impact and the
other
aspects for our body and psychedelic
work etc is also tremendously impactful
so that's saying a lot so so I say thank
you for for your bravery and um thanks
Andrew yeah it's um
it's crazy because I think that a lot of
people
um
can imagine telling a story or to a
close friend or something but you know
to put it out into the world you know
it's like it's huge like you don't know
how that's gonna Ripple
um and you've been a real Pioneer an
example for uh for me for for lacks for
other people and revealing things not
like that um but different and Peter
Attias recently been opening up about
some serious challenges that he's had in
his and his book he does that on podcast
he's been doing it so
um you know yet another category
um arguably the most important category
for
um exploration and sharing and you know
thoughtful bravery right because you
didn't just put it out there in any form
so uh one thing I do know by experience
is there's nothing weirder than being uh
told thank you for the painful thing
that you did so I don't want to push
that too far but I'd be remiss if I
didn't because it really has its impact
and for doing it again here today
because
um so yeah that huge thanks for doing
that yeah my my pleasure and I'll also
say you know I got advice from
very very experienced uh psychedelic
facilitator at one point who said
take the pain and make it part of your
medicine
and
the way I think that applies here
is
we all experience pain we all experience
suffering
many of us have experienced trauma of
one type or another
and
that can consume you I mean it can
consume you but it's like fire right it
can consume you but you can also harness
it and use it for different things
and
I know for I think it's I'm not going to
hedge I'll say I know for a fact that
there are people I've spoken to
who are suicidal and by the way I'm not
inviting everyone who's listening if you
are suicidal to reach out to because it
won't work I've had to disengage from
that because it gets too heavy right
just to engage one-on-one with people
who are suicidal but there are resources
in that post I mentioned the Practical
thoughts on suicide
but let's just talk about closer friends
people you would never suspect in a
million years who are this close to
blowing their friends out
people folks would recognize in some
cases
the fact that I was also there once is
why they listen to me
because I have unfortunately I'm a
subject matter expert man I have
credibility
and that actually is very redeeming
it provides some meaning to the
suffering that I experienced it's like
okay
here I am
for whatever host of reasons I am put in
this place and time with this person
and they don't trust the input of these
other people they're talking to because
those people don't know what it's like
but I can look at this person in the eye
and be like oh I know
and that's just a different thing so you
can
you can find a way to transmute that
pain
into
something meaningful into a gift that
hopefully you can share in some way
not necessarily with the whole wide
world just one person that's a big deal
one person's a big deal
there's a lot out there that is intended
for Mass consumption that gets in front
of millions of people doesn't really
impact a single person very much
so even if you don't have a podcast you
don't have books if you have the ability
to sit down with one person and really
make an impact that's actually more
meaningful than most of the crap that
gets put out there
so take heart
Amen to that
I'd like to spend a little bit of time
talking about the roles you see yourself
in you know I I had this list coming in
here of okay you've done the exploration
of the health sphere you
um self-experimentation you
you're uh you've been an investor you
are an investor you're a podcaster
you're you know I think these are more
than titles I think
titles are great but titles are what we
get from other people telling us what we
do or deciding what we do
um
I'm more interested in how you think
about yourself like your your own role
identity and you know I have to assume
you've spent a little bit of time on
this like if one were to go through the
the checklist of possible roles yeah
right okay I confess I do this I think
like okay like I I think I call I think
I checked the box of animal because
we're we're animals after all or you
know humans don't pole dancing I think
I'd use a pole dancer absolutely not
um are you still Tango dancing
I'm planning on getting back into it
great and that is that does have some
background I have Argentine lineage and
I'm embarrassed to say I don't tank uh
no Tango but you got the man you got the
mate in the in the Green Room my uh
grandparents uh Tango into their 80s I
think late 80s yeah it is yeah eight
steak and smoke cigarettes and uh lived
until their 90s exactly
um
but I'm curious about the roles that you
see yourself in like you know um roll
identity to me is so important
um in terms of where we see ourselves
now and where we see ourselves going
forward and who knows maybe you don't
have any role identity plan but you know
what are some boxes that you see
yourself in now that you really strongly
identify with and then what are some
boxes that um you'd like to check off
going forward
so current
boxes
I would say the two that I probably
identify with most
maybe three
but I'll focus on two experimentalists
which can take a lot of forms right that
can that can apply to a whole lot of
different spheres
so experimentalist
and then teacher
and for the longest time
long long time I thought eventually I
would go back and actually be a ninth
grade teacher because I feel like that
is such a critical window for so many
kids where they can
either
hit an inflection point and go in a
really good direction or they can go in
a really bad Direction and I certainly
saw that online Long Island with a lot
of my friends a lot of overdoses a bunch
of friends who've died of
opiate addiction and various things and
I had some intervention with mentors
early on that
that sort of flipped the switch on the
railroad track and sent me in a
different direction so I thought for a
long time I would go back
and be a ninth grade teacher and my
impulse to experiment leads to
enthusiasm for teaching
if that makes any sense because I feel
like
as good as I might be or decent at
taking a complex subject
deconstructing it applying 80 20.
putting things in order and learning
things very quickly
which includes
stress testing assumptions in that
sort of assumed progression for skill
like language learning there's so many
myths in language learning as an example
if it takes me say six months to become
reasonably competent in field X I can
usually get other people to that same
point of confidence in a third of that
time
so for me it's very gratifying to teach
and I view all the books as teaching
tools I'm no tool story I recognize I'm
not the world's greatest writer I take
the writing seriously
I don't have asset I do many many
revisions even for talk much it's like
27 revisions for a short story called
so I take it seriously but I recognize
that I'm not the world's greatest
Wordsmith but I am looking for outcomes
in readers or listeners and I view my
job as that of teacher so I'd say
experimentalist and teacher of the two
and
those both go a long way
applies to
say dog training you know lots of ran
lots of experiments and for those
listening to him just looked under the
table one thing I should have said at
the beginning and I did not is that um
this is the first human Lab podcast to
feature a guest who brought their dog so
we have Molly is here as well and we're
absolutely delighted there has not been
a dog at on the huberman Lab podcast
since uh Costello passed away and uh I'm
you know practically floating in in
Delight that Molly's here today she's
amazing and you've done an amazing job
training her too so thank you yeah she's
she's laying right next to my feet
licking my hand as I speak so good and
I'd say if I were to expand that by one
I would probably say explore but the
exploring goes hand in hand with the
experimentation
uh so
that could be Geographic exploration it
could be spending time with people who
are excellent at anything
in any field
and seeing where that gingerbread Trail
leads me
and I think the the exploration and the
experimentation are for me
bedfellows they go together
what about roles that you would like to
explore or potentially see yourself in I
mean I don't have a magic wand but if I
did as a fellow podcaster and I consider
you a friend uh I would say okay like if
I could wand you to the success and
given role that wouldn't be the way it
would work and that wouldn't be as
gratifying as having to figure it all
out because that's part of your your
Machinery uh as you just told us so yeah
what are some role life roles that
you're interested in expanding and or
stepping into that you haven't explored
I'd say more more artists more Artistry
especially in the visual sense because I
wanted to be a comic book penciler for a
really long time got paid as an
illustrator towards the end of high
school and during college so Illustrated
books and magazines and so on then I
just dropped it I dropped it when I
graduated because I was kid stuff and it
was time to get serious and be an adult
and I just cold turkey to stop all of it
and so the skills of atrophied a lot but
there's still there's still a bit in
there I've seen some posts on Instagram
that were yeah quite good so I'm still
messing around yeah I'm still messing
around and especially when I have some
structure I do well so I'd like to
pursue that I would like to experiment
with
animation
so I don't know if animator would be the
right label because I most likely would
not be doing the animation myself but
playing a role in visual art would be
one father would be another one
eventually
and try not to be attached to it but
we all play games of various types and
if we get really good at certain games
that are socially rewarded then you make
money doing
a podcast or investing or whatever it
might be
but when my
when when when the sort of ramp of my
learning starts to flatten out a bit I
tend to get bored of those games and I
think that
certainly one of the biggest adventures
must be Parenthood
so at some point
I think
father
would be on there
and I should say this is very judgmental
to me to say but I think there's a big
difference between wanting to
wanting to be a parent and wanting to
have kids I'm very cautious about saying
I want to have kids because it doesn't
automatically imply you want to be a
good parent
which is also why I thought it was very
important for me to spend a lot of time
training Molly
and a lot of learning there right yeah
she's like all right am I going to do
the heavy lifting and the hard work
recognizing that kids are not deferred
dogs but I do think they're actually a
lot of similarities uh in terms of
just predictive ability if you see
someone who has dogs that are terribly
trained
look at their kids you might see some
similarities my good friend
um my good friend I'll owed him here
who's a mdp issu is their chair of
Ophthalmology at Stanford Jeff Goldberg
I once asked him if he has any pets and
he said that he and his wife had three
children as preparation for having a dog
that's hilarious there's a quote also
from a book called Don't Shoot the dog
which is terrible title but excellent
book written by Karen Pryor who was a an
aquatic mammal trainer so she's training
dolphins and whales and so on which
don't respond to negative reinforcement
you can't really hit them with a rolled
up newspaper if they don't do what you
want and there's a quote in that book
which is something along the lines of I
can't remember the attribution it's
another trainer and it was people should
not be allowed to have children until
they've successfully trained a chicken
[Laughter]
because also chickens like they they
just don't have the brain power to
respond to uh much negative
reinforcement so you have to coax them
to do what you want them to do with
positive reinforcement and I mean
operate in classical conditioning it's
kind of same same across the board
whether you're like a CIA trying to
train cockroaches to flip lights which
is not making that one up by the way or
training wheel or training a cat or
training a human uh training sounds bad
cultivating
a wonderful human yeah then I think
there's a lot to be learned across the
board so I've successfully proven to
myself that I can keep a dog alive and
happy yeah and train up another happy
nervous system yeah you know curate
another nervous system and that's a big
deal oh yeah well she's also like my
external nervous system so we we sort of
work in tandem I pay a lot of attention
to how she relates to different people
yeah I saw earlier today I mean as
someone who is the owner of a Bulldog
Mastiff who knew one command which was
weight which is which is that by default
the easiest thing to train a bulldog
because it when when you by the way
folks if you stop a bulldog on the
street to scratch them and they look
delighted they might like you but
chances are they're just really relieved
that they get to stop
so and
um Costello he had a forebrain and he
was smart about what he needed to be
smart about but Molly is exceptional
like she knows where she needs to be and
she's super connected to you and she
knows a ton of commands it was
ridiculous our staff was like delighting
in the number of things that Tim could
get her to do just by looking at her
yeah yeah yeah she's uh she's also quite
calm out of the box
uh which helps although it makes it
harder in some respects to train because
she doesn't have much food drive if you
like those Maui new Easter eggs yeah she
loves the Maui News venison sticks but
she
well okay I'll get I'll give I'll say
two things so first is if your dog is a
spaz about food that's actually great
news it will make your dog very easy to
train in some respects
uh re-don't shoot the dog it's it's
excellent
and there's some others I could
recommend I had a woman named uh Susan
Garrett on my podcast because I wanted
an objective measure of successful dog
training and competitors have objective
measures so she was in a dog agility
Champion for many years which has a lot
of metrics so anyway I had herons people
are interested but the
the the tip that I got from one dog
trainer early on because I was trying to
train Molly and I was using just some of
her kibble I'd like put some kibble in a
bag and carry it around and she was like
what are you doing and I said what do
you mean what am I doing she's like is
that kibble I'm like yeah it's kibble
and she goes she's like hey pal she's
like you're at a crowded bar you got a
tip with 20s to get your dogs attention
you take your lovely to the dog park
it's like squirrels other dogs grass
piss on the pavement whatever it happens
to be you have to have good treats so if
your dog isn't responding chances are
maybe you're trying to tip with singles
I love it I love it
well thank you for sharing the roles you
see yourself in and the ones that you'd
like to
step into more uh I certainly feel I
have the jurisdiction to say that you
are an exceptional experimentalist and a
phenomenal teacher we've seen this
across so many you're welcome and and
I'm not just speaking for myself I'm
sleeping speaking for so many other
people as well I mean we've seen this
across so many domains it's like
blogging podcasting book writing
stage lecturing being a guest on a
podcast you know and on and on and um in
terms of the roles that you want to
expand into more I I can't wait to see
the illustrations that that emerge yeah
please do uh grow that flame because I
I'm excited for what comes out um
punch being
um just the first of them leading the
charge yeah
um and uh
you know
I can say because I know uh because I
have one and because I um uh I've
observed many uh kids and friends uh who
are fathers you're gonna be an
exceptional father
I'm absolutely confident of that thanks
man yeah I appreciate that yeah
and I want to say thanks for taking the
time to talk with me today I've been
looking forward to this so much my team
knows this wait we were sort of buzzing
like yeah we've had some Heavy Hitters
on this podcast you know uh we only look
to the top one percent in field and
they're you know incredibly credentialed
by whatever standards we happen to be
exploring and they have to be people
that I really want to talk to so
um I have so much respect for what you
do and the way you do it uh you've
certainly inspired me this podcast would
not exist I don't think the genre of
podcasting would exist and look the way
that it does had you not made the
decision to start podcasting and
um in anticipation of this episode I did
put out a ping on Twitter for questions
and there were many many of them
um that maybe we'll do a q a sometime
maybe not who knows but you know one of
the questions that really stood out to
me was you know how does Tim feel about
all these other people coming into all
the spaces that he's worked and doing
um successful work that builds off so
much of what he's done and uh I'll let
you answer but for me I can say that
um I've been positively inspired and
built so much of what we've been doing
here and
um and what I think about based on the
ways that you've podcasted and
communicate with the public and maintain
your stance and integrity in the way
that you interact with people it's
really inspiring and you've always been
so gracious to me and so humble and so
giving and um and at the same time I
know there's a fierce guy in there who
likes to get it done so once again
thanks for being first man in thanks for
taking on all the roles that you have
and that you are and that you will and
thanks for being a giver we all benefit
thanks Andrew
uh I really appreciate you saying all
that and
I want people to just get after it take
things seriously have fun and be really
really good so watching for instance
what you've done which has been so
spectacular so well executed
makes me super happy and I don't view
anyone as competition
uh in the podcasting world for instance
in the book world I don't view it that
way either
and
I just hope that people keep
experimenting pushing the envelope
and if people aren't say getting better
over time if people aren't following who
are substantially better than me in all
of these ways
uh then I would be super disappointed so
every time I see someone doing something
really impressive or doing something I
never would have thought of I get so
extremely excited I find it really fun
to watch so
appreciate you also
just getting out there and hard charging
and taking your podcast as seriously as
you do I mean I've seen the notes I've
seen the setup I met the team
it's it's very inspiring for me also
makes me want to dust off my cleats and
get back on the field so man you've
never left the field and you've had a
hand in it all so thank you so much and
um hope you'll come back and visit us
again here yeah I hope so it's been a
real pleasure I've been looking forward
to this for a long time as well and I
appreciate you inviting me on
until next time till next time man thank
you for joining me for today's
discussion with Tim Ferriss I hope you
found it to be as informative and as
actionable as I did for links to Tim's
books as well as for a link to his
weekly blog please see the show note
captions you'll also find a link to
Tim's podcast the Tim Ferriss podcast
and I highly recommend that you
subscribe and listen to the Tim Ferriss
podcast
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a five
star review
if you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to include on the huberman Lab
podcast please put those in the comments
section on YouTube I do read all the
comments please also check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not on
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like enhancing sleep for
hormone support and for Focus the
uberman Lab podcast is proud to have
partnered with momentous supplements to
see the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast go to live
momentous spelled ous so that's
livemomentis.com huberman again that's
livemomentous.com huberman if you're not
already following us on social media I
am huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and at all those
places I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlaps
with the content of the huberman Lab
podcast but much of which often does not
overlap with the content of the human
Lab podcast so again it's huberman lab
on all social media Platforms in
addition if you haven't subscribed to
our neural network newsletter it's a
zero cost monthly newsletter that
provides summaries of podcast episodes
as well as tool kits for instance
toolkits for optimizing sleep or
toolkits for Learning and
neuroplasticity or for deliberate cold
exposure for dopamine and on and on to
sign up for the neural network
newsletter simply go to hubermanlab.com
go to the menu scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Tim Ferriss and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]